[Music]
folks my name is Doug Vincent chair of
the tech day committee I'm really
excited today it's a beautiful day
outside there's not a lot of things that
would draw me inside today but this the
program we have for you today is one of
those things we have had so much fun
putting this program together working
with these five outstanding faculty
members couldn't be happier than to
share that with you all today we have a
little bit different format this year
we've delayed lunch until after 12:45 so
our five speakers will all be before
lunch we'll hear from three of them have
a break including some fruit and granola
and rejoin here for the last two and at
the end we'll have some some questions
and answers the president Hockfield will
moderate that we have live feed
downstairs two little Kresge and we'll
go through some more the details for
questions and answers a little bit later
in this program the goal of that is so
this afternoon folks are free to explore
the campus participate in other class
activities and so forth so bear with us
for a little bit lengthened morning
program we think you'll find it worth
the while I need to say thank you to the
Alumni Association for the faith that
they continue to have in the tech Day
committee thank you to the committee
outstanding year and of course thank you
to lou alexander outstanding just a
pleasure to work with you if folks would
reach to wherever they have their cell
phones right now and find the button on
it that says off and turn that off I
appreciate that thank you
just like to introduce now Beth Garvin
executive vice president and CEO of the
MIT Alumni Association Beth
good morning it's a pleasure to see so
many familiar faces and even more
exciting to see so many unfamiliar faces
I hope I get a chance to say hello to
each of you personally and welcome
welcome you back to MIT Doug and I were
just chatting before the program started
and I said don't give me much of an
introduction because nobody wants to
hear from you or me Doug
they're here to hear from the president
and to hear from these marvelous faculty
he noted however that yeah we're just
the glue that holds it together and I'd
like to acknowledge that glue in the
Technology Day Committee in all the
reunion committee volunteers the reunion
gift committee volunteers reunion row
volunteers Tech Challenge game
volunteers all the hundreds of people
who have helped make check reunions 2005
a fabulous success from all accounts
it's been my joy this year to be able to
introduce our 16th president Susan
Hockfield to all of you and to introduce
the Alumni to her it has been just a
remarkable journey as we first announced
Susan's naming and any of you with an
email address that we know have heard
from me multiple times about how I think
this has been such a wonderful choice
for MIT and what a wonderful fit dr.
Hockfield is for MIT at this point in
time so without any further ado all of
the background is in your program book
and I'm sure you've already read of
Susan's remarkable accomplishments so I
do nothing more than turn it over to
president Hockfield
thank you
please it's a great pleasure to be here
this morning Thank You Beth it's been a
real treat for me to travel the country
with you and to have you by my side
introducing me to alumni from coast to
coast one of the things that has
impressed me enormous ly about MIT is
the kind of energy that just emanates
from the place you walked down the
corridor isn't the place of just
bursting with energy but that energy is
carried inside the people the place and
so as I traveled the country with Beth
and her band of just tireless troopers
you know having them by my side and
having them introduced me to many of you
over the last what is it now almost six
months has just been an incredible
delight and a treat the MIT alumni are
indeed a very special brunch special in
so many ways especially that you could
have finally brought spring to Cambridge
we thank you for that it's been a grim
spring but this weekend is the first you
know real burst of sunshine that makes
us feel optimistic that we actually
might have a summer here it's just been
wonderful to sample the treats of this
reunion weekend
my only regret people have asked me what
I regret what are the what are the
things I don't like about my job and my
response is always the thing I don't
like is only having 24 hours a day and
that's the way I feel about these
several days I mean I wish I could leave
live every hour of these days three
times over so that I could be at all of
the events and meet more of you than I'm
going to unfortunately have a chance to
meet this weekend I hope I know I've met
many of you and I will be meeting
several more of you many more of you
over the next several hours through the
end of this reunion weekend but I
promise you in the months and years to
come I will be getting around to meeting
all of you so it's great to be here this
morning's program is wonderful I can
take absolutely no credit for it there
are many happy coincidences I've seen
over the last six months and certainly
the topic for this morning's program is
a very happy coincidence those of you
who read or heard my inauguration
address know that one of the things I
drew out among the very very many
exciting opportunities and challenges
for MIT going forward is
fantastic convergence between the life
sciences and engineering and this
morning's program exemplifies that in
just startling ways in addition the
content of this program that you will
hear exemplifies the intellectual rigor
and the work at the frontiers of
knowledge that really do define MIT as
an institution I know that the devotion
of alumni is one of our absolutely
greatest strengths and keeping MIT
strong and vibrant is a team effort that
involves all of you as well as all of us
on campus but this great community of
MIT that reaches across the country
across the world is perfectly in line
with the Institute's fundamentally
collaborative spirit at MIT something
that I've learned is that we have a gift
for learning from one another we excel
at the kinds of intellectual interaction
that pushed conventional boundaries and
established new fields of study new
industries and new ways of thinking
about the world
the collaborations that MIT Fosters
depend on our remarkable culture of
openness I've been struck by how the
very architecture of the main group
symbolizes this the main group was
imagined and then constructed imagined
by Bosworth as one huge but
interconnected building with corridors
that linked the entire expanse of these
enormous buildings our historic campus
embodies the vision of an institution
without internal boundaries a place
where people who are interested in
similar problems can work together
freely across what might otherwise be
disciplinary divides in its design the
main group has actually helped invent
MIT and helped MIT invent the future in
the years ahead we will continue to
capitalize on our spirit of openness to
create new partnerships across our own
schools and departments and with other
institutions in the public and private
sectors collaboration is absolutely
essential if we are to fulfill
my tea's mission of bringing knowledge
to bear on the world's great problems
the challenges facing us today from
climate change to the future of social
security to the startling spread
contagious diseases are inherently
multidisciplinary now mi t--'s distinct
ability to catalyze work at the
interfaces of existing disciplines also
depends on a single uniform standard of
excellence over the course of this year
I found in uncompromising dedication to
excellence in all of our departments and
schools we see it in the faculty and the
students and also in the staff around
the Institute I think this morning's
program will demonstrate what I mean
today's faculty presenters are
absolutely stellar researchers but
they're also stellar teachers and
members devoted members generous members
of the MIT community and they will be
talking about some of our eras most
exciting advances in science and
technology this generation is bearing
witness to a fascinating convergence of
engineering and the life sciences this
convergence holds the promise of
transforming our lives but this kind of
convergence is not unprecedented it's a
convergence that we saw not so long ago
and we know this precedent 70 years ago
President Karl Compton insisted that the
physical scientists physical sciences
must play a critical role in education
and research at MIT and the result of
bringing in the physical sciences into
conversation with engineering produced
nothing less than a new era for
engineering which MIT pioneered to
appreciate the power of the kinds of
collaborations that Compton helped spawn
through the 20th century's big
convergence you only have to think about
the radiation lab that helped develop
radar and helped us win World War two
today
engineering is making the same kind of
fertile connections with life sciences
and I believe we can expect equally
revolutionary results combining MIT s
historic strengths and engineering and
our newer strengths and biology in the
brain and cognitive sciences we're
already opening up unprecedented
opportunities for educational innovation
for invention and for discovery we're
pioneering new educational areas as well
as new research directions we have
biological variants of several of the
engineering majors and next fall we're
going to be initiating a new major in
biological engineering
I think this tech day program will show
you how MIT is leading the way in this
new field of all fields just as we have
led the way in disciplines that define
the information age I think it also
demonstrates the tremendous
contributions MIT can and will be making
to this nation and the world I've been
looking forward to hearing these faculty
presenters talk about their research for
months and I am delighted to have the
luxury of sitting in the audience with
all of you today I'm anticipating an
exciting program and I'm sure that MIT
will prove as it has done over the last
several months that my anticipation
cannot even come close to what we were
actually going to experience so enjoy
the afternoon and enjoy the morning and
I will return I promise you it's only
going to be the morning but I'm gonna
return at the end to moderate the
question period so enjoy this morning's
presentations thank you
[Applause]
it's great every once in a while I think
a group like the tech tech committee
gets lucky and we selected last fall
bioengineering and then to be honored
with the president Hockfield first time
presiding over today it's sometimes you
get you get lucky and about that last
fall when we were looking at this topic
trying to understand what how do we
construct this program we sat down with
Professor Doug Lofton Berger and he just
gave us an education and we were so
thrilled and learned so much we said
jeez
what do you think can you can you do
that on a broader scale he said
absolutely remarkably he thanked us this
morning for being a part of it when in
fact really we think he and all the
faculty for their time to put together
today's program doug is the director of
mi t--'s bioengineering division and at
this point just turn it over to dark
[Applause]
thank you very much Doug and it's a
privilege to be part of this day with
all the alumni and Friends coming back
we'll see if there's any continuing
adjustment that needs to be done and
I'll be darned
it was what I'm going to give you is not
the research excitement itself I have to
lay out the context for what's happening
at MIT and why it's happening why is
happening now why it's happening here
and that's the purpose of this talk so I
talked about the landscape of
bioengineering at MIT and how we're
breaking new ground in this landscape
now those of you who haven't been back
for a while know that this landscape has
been changing dramatically to breaking
new ground all over the local blocks
with new buildings and new excitement
and so that's been changing as well but
that's not the landscape that I mean I
want to talk about the intellectual
landscape of the interface between
engineering and biology now there has
been a traditional biomedical
engineering landscape both at MIT and
around the country and this has been
around for about 40 years there's been a
field known as biomedical engineering
bioengineering medical engineering at
many places and what it's been all about
is essentially the marriage of the
classical engineering disciplines in
which students are trained in
mathematics and physics and chemistry
married with medicine to solve medical
problems in ways there are technologies
based on mathematics and physics and
chemistry could now one important
feature of this is that it's a
multidisciplinary application field all
the different engineering fields could
bring what they had to bear in contact
with medicine and solve problems from
their own unique disciplinary
backgrounds accordingly
from the MIT point of view this was
never appropriate as an undergraduate
major degree of study because you were
better off studying in any of the other
classical engineering disciplines and
applying your interests to medicine if
you if you so wished at the graduate
level of course since you were taking
these other engineering disciplinary
backgrounds and using them to solve
medical problems that was a very
appropriate type of graduate study to do
with in any of the MIT engineering
departments electrical engineering and
computer science mechanical engineering
material science Chemical Engineering
and so forth and many of these programs
benefited from interaction with the
Health Sciences technology and it's
connection to Harvard Medical School the
other feature is that the bio in the bio
engineering and biomedical engineering
has for those 40 years in these programs
essentially been organ level physiology
which is of course crucial for medicine
but is essentially descriptive that's
not the mechanisms by which living
systems operate so you could describe
what was going on in engineering terms
and try to work at it from the outside
but you couldn't control the underlying
mechanisms so that's what's been around
for 40 years and it's very important had
very valuable contributions and will
continue to have variable valuable
contributions and will continue at MIT
with in all these other departments
these kind of contributions have been
manifested in a variety of career
opportunities carried out by MIT alums
and probably many of you have been
working in these very fields medical
devices of all sorts Diagnostics like
imaging and prosthetics implants
extracorporeal devices maybe the
pharmaceuticals industry and processing
manufacturing and delivery and in all
these very important contributions of
biomedical engineering careers the one
interesting feature is that training of
engineers in the actual bios biological
science fundamentals really wasn't
crucial you had to be really good at
your math and your physics and your
chemistry and interface with a
physiological problem that was what was
crucial rather than the biological
science itself all right with that as a
40-year backdrop
now what is new besides many buildings
going up what is new in the
bioengineering landscape well as
president Hockfield told you we have now
created something brand new and in fact
I will assert unique a biology based
engineering discipline that we call
biological engineering instead of being
an engineering discipline rooted solely
in math and physics or math and physics
and chemistry this one is rooted in the
molecular life sciences what's at the
core of it is genetics biochemistry
molecular biology cell biology it's us
this engineering discipline is rooted in
the mechanisms by which living systems
operate the very molecules and cells
that make things happen for good or ill
but these Sciences are fused with
engineering and analysis and synthesis
just like all the other engineering
disciplines fused analysis and synthesis
with physics and chemistry and so forth
so it's focused on taking these life
sciences and understanding them in a
quantitative and systems oriented way
and designing new technologies based on
these biological molecular and cellular
components and mechanisms so once you
have a discipline now that's just like
Electrical Engineering mechanical
engineering Chemical Engineering but is
now rooted in a different science now
MIT has agreed that this is appropriate
for standalone degree programs both a
new ph.d program that we started in 1999
and what's quite exciting is a new
bachelor's degree program that starts
this very fall all right but why has
this changed happened why was this
traditional landscape for 40 years and
now something very radically new is
happening why is engineering and biology
interaction changing so dramatically
because the biological science itself
has changed so dramatically the
engineering can't change in a
revolutionary way unless the science has
changed in a revolutionary way and
that's what's happened in the past 20
years there have been two major
revolutions in biology the molecular
revolution roughly in the 80s the
genomic revolution rough
in the 90s so if you took biological
science before the 80s you did not learn
these types of biological science this
has all happened in the last 20 years I
went to college in the 1970s and in the
1970s I did not learn this kind of
biological science so what was the
engineering biology interface quote then
before these revolutions back when I
took biological science in the 1970s it
honestly was not amenable to engineering
analysis and synthesis and design
engineers could not access biology
before these revolutions because
biological science didn't understand the
actual mechanisms few of the actual
components the parts had been identified
you could only quantify things at these
higher organ levels of hierarchy which
is why engineers worked at the organ
physiology level you certainly couldn't
manipulate any of the molecular
components even if you identified them
there was nothing you could do about
them a gene was a gene and a protein was
a protein I
there wasn't enough data to build models
and design and it was hard to generalize
from humans to mice to rats to worms and
so forth so the modern era of
bioengineering really began with the
molecular biology revolution in
essentially the 1980s because that
permitted mechanistic components to be
identified and manipulated and you can't
engineer anything unless you know what
the components are and you can
manipulate them I just show this for
illustration this is a bone and for all
the traditional years of biomedical
engineering bone could be perceived and
dealt with only on the basis of being
this macroscopic load-bearing mechanical
object for instance my mother has had
six hip replacements many years ago she
crushed her hip falling off a bicycle
and what could biomedical engineers do
about that well pre the revolution all
they could do is replace that hip as say
a mechanical load-bearing substitute
first wood crutches then metals the
implants became metals then
plastics the in paints became plastics
and none of them worked very long for
variety reasons mainly that they really
weren't bone they didn't interact with a
surrounding tissue in the immune
response they didn't respond properly
the stress and so forth but with the
molecular biology revolution now we know
this isn't just some macroscopic
load-bearing object what has been
identified as cells that are dynamically
breaking it down building it up the
proteins by which the cells are
stimulated to break down bone and build
it up and the genes that encode for the
proteins that tell the cells what to
break down and to build up and so now we
have the hope of regenerating not wood
metal or plastic but regenerating living
bone and you'll hear a little bit of
that from Professor Griffith in a minute
so the very fact of identifying what the
mechanistic components are and being
able to do something to manipulate them
was crucial now this modern air has been
catalyzed by the genomic biology
revolution in which just depicted here
are a large number of sequencers
cranking out the identities of genes in
your chromosomes and what kind of
proteins they might get a code for and
so forth because this has accelerated
the rate at which molecular compounds
can be identified instead of one by one
in a hard slog we can now find tens and
hundreds and thousands of them at once
so this ability of finding the parts has
just been dramatically accelerated the
concomitant has been showing even how
much more complex these mechanisms are
than her previously appreciated people
had hoped with the onset of molecular
biology that if you could find maybe one
gene or one protein you could just fix
something in a disease would go away the
genomic revolution looking at tens and
hundreds of thousands of the components
and their interactions at once now have
made us realize that's going to be
really difficult these are very complex
networks and machines so these twenty
years of to biology revolutions have led
us to
a now engineering biology interface
that's just night and day different not
only is biology amenable to engineering
analysis and synthesis we have parts we
can manipulate them but again I would
assert that biology benefits from and
maybe even requires the engineering
analysis and synthesis approach now
molecular complements are being
identified the mechanisms involved in
molecular and cell actions are being
elucidated quantitative analysis is
possible all the way from DNA structure
protein DNA interactions up through
molecular networks to cell functions of
tissue functions you can quantitatively
analyze every step along the way not
just at the organ level and molecular
components can now be easily manipulated
it's very simple to go in and change a
gene change a protein change any piece
you want what's the hard part the hard
part is to understand and predict what
happens when you're gonna do that right
now it's almost trial and error and
that's what we've got to get beyond and
that's where engineering comes in so we
believe that this is the time for a new
fusion of biology with engineering
because of these two revolutions the
molecular biology revolution finally
first for the first time permitted
engineers to access the science of
biology and the genomic revolution now
requires biology to be addressed by
engineering so we now have the parts we
can manipulate them and it's darn
complex and engineers really can get
involved and have to get involved just
as a few illustrations if we think it's
something like cells migrating the cells
of your immune response seeking out
cancer cells or viruses or healing a
wound how would you make that happen
how would you enhance the rate at which
wounds were healed or immune response
operated or if this is a tumor cell
metastasizing to an improper organ how
would you stop that well we have to
understand how this cell migration works
in terms of what's depicted here
schematically it's a machine
this is the cell and the membrane and
it's connected molecular li to the
extracellular matrix and allows the
cells to crawl and pull their way
through and the cell has motors inside
that are generating the forces in just
the right places it's an exquisite
molecular machine and we need to
understand it in terms of molecular
structures and properties and biophysics
in biomechanics and these machines
aren't autonomous they're not
spontaneous they're highly regulated the
cells will migrate under some conditions
and not other other conditions they'll
proliferate under some conditions and
not other other conditions
what's regulating them well there's a
fascinating set of biomolecular signal
processing circuits that take
information from the environment and say
what should I do now should I migrate
should I not should I proliferate should
I not should I die I'm a stem cell
should I differentiate into something
else
how do I decide so they take their
information from their surroundings and
process those signals and change their
gene expression metabolism inside a
scale and so forth and carry out
different functions they do signal
processing so we need to understand this
regulation of the machines by these
signal processing networks the way
perhaps electrical engineers computer
scientists and so forth might think
about regulatory circuits in a
fascinating thing that's really becoming
like realistic to think about especially
at MIT because we realistically think
about things that most places really
only will speculate about there's an
opportunity of a field called synthetic
biology where folks on this campus and
others are trying to dizzy design these
machines and networks from scratch
instead of just intervening in them one
molecule here or there they're saying
can we design our own DNA sequences that
will produce the right proteins that
will interact in the right ways to build
a network or a machine with the right
sort of topology then that would carry
out a dynamic function of one sort or
another people are building their own
machines and networks from designing
their own DNA sequences
from scratch a fascinating field and
it's a it's starting here's a young
professor named drew endy who's really
the it's very interesting his assistant
professor and he's known as the father
of the field so that doesn't happen very
often now at the same time we start with
these mechanistic underpinnings we say
to an end for an engineer to access
biology you've got to have the parts
gotta know what the parts are you got to
be able to manipulate the parts but of
course you don't do that in a vacuum you
want to think about what higher level
functions you're aiming at whether it's
physiology pathology therapeutic
interventions brand-new devices like I
suggested on the previous slide
brand-new materials
professor Belcher will talk about brand
new materials from bio molecular
mechanisms rounds as the second round
we'll talk about new types of
therapeutics from these molecular
mechanisms so you've got to think about
the complexity of biology in one
dimension which is many many components
at once in another dimension of all the
information you know about it sequence
structure thermodynamics kinetics
mechanics and in the other dimension of
the physiological complexity individual
cells cells and population cells and
tissues and so forth so the underlying
mechanisms govern the higher level
functions and to an engineer if this is
the way we think that you're thinking
about higher level system function and
how are you going to design that or how
you gonna intervene in it from the
molecular and cellular components so
there is something that we call this
discipline of biological engineering
that is both the discipline important
for science and for technology and it
looks a lot in these first few bullets
it should look just like any of the
other engineering disciplines maybe you
studied Chemical Engineering mechanical
engineering Electrical Engineering and
so forth because you and it will analyze
complicated many component hierarchical
systems you do that and all those other
engineering disciplines
you'll synthesize designed technologies
not trial and error we don't build any
other technologies by trial and error
it's time that we really stopped doing
medicine by trial and error and I think
Martha Gray will talk about that as well
and all engineers operate with this
paradigm there's different ways to pose
it but measure and model and manipulate
with design principles and parameters
computational models and so forth
construct your own copy components to
have the right properties it's the only
difference between biological
engineering and all the other
engineering disciplines is what are our
components and mechanisms in other cases
it might be organic chemistry inorganic
chemistry solid-state physics in our
case it's biological molecules
biological machines and networks and the
cells that comprise essentially the
organizing principles for these so just
like any other engineer except the
science is different but the science is
still quantitative manipulable
components so it's clear to us that this
is time to have created a new biology
based engineering discipline to sit
alongside its sibling disciplines in the
School of Engineering in the idea of
creating a new engineering discipline
isn't new mit does this every few
decades okay
Electrical Engineering mechanical
engineering at one point in time didn't
exist at one point in time they were
established
as now physics based engineering
disciplines a hundred years ago Chemical
Engineering didn't exist materials of
Science and Engineering really didn't
exist and they came into being as
chemistry based engineering disciplines
so now we are in the 21st century
creating another one it just happens to
be a biology based engineering
discipline and the biology is molecular
life sciences and it comprises both
technology and science facets we are
designing and developing biology based
technologies as you'll see in the
ensuing
talks and at the same time I think we're
facilitating the advance of the science
itself turning engineering back to the
science and how can we understand it
better so it's a two-way street
between the science and the technology
as any good engineering discipline
really is I won't go into this in much
detail but we are very excited about the
new biological engineering major that
starts this fall
professor Griffith who talks who speaks
next was really the principal architect
of this it's been an immense amount of
time constructing this in partnership
with many other departments and all I
want to show you is the science core
beyond the typical freshman year
requires organic chemistry biochemistry
molecular cell biology genetics just as
I said
along with the mathematics that one
would require and then what's listed
here our nine brand new courses we
didn't just sort of cobble together oh
let's borrow a course from let's borrow
a subject from this department and the
subject from that department a subject
from that department these are nine new
courses all designed from scratch saying
if we're going to understand and
manipulate this kind of biology of
genetics and biochemistry and molecular
and cell biology what is the way an
engineer would do that what's the right
thermodynamics to study this science
what's the right mechanics to study this
science what's the right signal
processing or fields or control or
computation you can't just borrow the
same old and sew them together it's
brand-new engineering because it's
brand-new science so these are brand new
subjects and a lot of faculty effort but
the faculty are very enthusiastic about
this what's the point of learning this
new discipline we're very convinced and
we have lots of a confident input
likewise from our friends out in
industry that there's going to be new
types of places that engineers have
never been hired before because
engineers haven't been capable of
knowing this kind of a science
so yes medical devices but instead of
building the boxes these folks are going
to design a manipulate the interactions
of these devices with their environment
so maybe you still have a prosthetic hip
maybe we can't quite
generate my mother's hip from cells and
genes and proteins quite yet but her hip
may fail less if we can figure out how
to eat interphase that synthetic
material with the immune fly immune
response the inflammatory response the
surrounding tissue and so forth so that
it doesn't fail there medical
diagnostics but now will be in terms of
these biological mechanisms analysis
will be at the gene and molecule and
cell levels the appropriate information
technology we can imagine selling this
tissue based therapeutics engineers will
be involved in the pharmaceutical and
biotech industries not just to
manufacture and to deliver but to
actually design and to develop to
discover these kind of biological
engines will help facilitate the
discovery of ret the right targets
should be what the right therapeutics
should be because of their ability to
think in a quantitative systems oriented
manner about these very very complex
systems and all the way along the way to
predict pharmacology effects toxicology
effects and so forth and finally but
maybe even more importantly in terms of
the scope biological engineers will not
only contribute to medicine and human
health in a very powerful new way they
we believe will transform many of the
other non health associated fields
creating new types of materials and
devices in perhaps environmentally
benign manner with much more controlled
properties things you'll hear from
Professor Belcher understanding better
toxicology environmental health the
pathogens the toxins carcinogens in our
environment National Defense new types
of biological sensors and actuators that
can carry out functions in far more
exquisite ways then physics and
chemistry might by themselves so let me
end sort of pictorially the traditional
bio a biology medicine engineering
landscape looked something like this
imagine problems driven by applications
in health care maybe clinical hospital
aerospace military maybe the
pharmaceutical device Diagnostics
industries
and I'm speaking only about the
engineering disciplines here certainly
the science disciplines would be
analogous situation you could take any
one of these engineering disciplines
Chemical Engineering Electrical
Engineering mechanical engineering
material science based on chemistry
physics and math the way it has been for
40 years interface with medicine be a
wonderful biomedical engineer in solve
problems in the healthcare field that's
been the traditional pathway and it's an
important pathway you can also
contribute to biotechnology perhaps in
the processing manufacturing and
delivering or so forth so what's new
what's new and some of you over here
won't be able to see this there will be
something new showing up in the bottom
left-hand corner which is the sibling
discipline of biological engineering
that according to the curriculum I just
showed you a couple slides ago now takes
as a central science base genetics
biochemistry molecular biology cell
biology and can very powerfully
interface with medicine and solve
biomedical engineering problems for the
healthcare industry it can also be
applied to novel types of bio
technologies both for the healthcare
industry in terms of therapeutics and in
other types of device diverse industries
as new materials the environment and so
forth so we're just placing this new
discipline alongside the old ones
because it has a new science space you
notice in parentheses in the middle I
have bioengineering because at MIT what
we've decided to do is call
bioengineering the whole scope so
biomedical engineering medical
engineering can think about is the
precise application regardless of the
engineering discipline itself - medical
problems biological engineering is this
new biology based discipline and then
bioengineering just covers the whole
scope so you can major in electrical
engineering minor in biomedical
engineering you can major in biology
minor in biomedical engineering or now
you can major in biological engineering
per se and have a whole world of
applications open to you
what I want to say about the landscape
this is another landscape that's changed
these are the faculty that are
affiliated with the biological
engineering department at this point in
time and if you can see the colors you
can see how the landscape has changed
the names in blue many of them who might
be familiar to you were members of the
department when we started in 1998 the
names in green have all been hired since
then and to give great credit to the
President and the provost and the deans
of these last few years of investing in
this brand new opportunity for MIT which
I truly believe we're at the forefront
of we're defining and the Institute has
been investing in in terms of its most
precious asset which is people finally
let me say to go back to this landscape
that it's crucial to emphasize that we
do this in partnership with the
Department of Biology we have a
wonderful what's a unique but it's
really unusual partnership between
biological engineering in this School of
Engineering and biology and the School
of Science in terms of faculty members
who have appointments in both courses
we've co-developed and co-teach parts of
the undergraduate curriculum that are
now transparent research programs and so
forth so biology is mainly located in
this brown box biological engineering is
mainly located in this blue box but we
have this wonderful handshake
partnership and I really think this
could have happened
only at MIT because of the world-class
biology department because of its own
role in defining the biology of the
molecular biology revolution and the
genomic biology revolution that they
could appreciate what we wanted to do
from the engineering school in having a
similar revolution in biological
engineering so I thank you for your
patience with this overview the real
excitements gonna come from the next few
people because they're going to show you
the fascinating things that were
actually doing but I hope this painted
you a picture of what is new why we're
doing it how we got there and why this
is really such an extraordinary point in
time thank you very much
[Applause]
Wow that's pretty incredible what a
remarkable turn of events these last few
years and what a great setup thank you
Doug for really teeing up the rest of
the excitement this morning I mean it is
a remarkable story about the courage the
vision the leadership to look to do this
and this is I think what I know I
certainly loved about MIT and I hope
this sort of thing continues next we're
going to hear from professor Linda
Griffith is that Doug talked about
professor Griffith was instrumental in
pulling together a new undergraduate
major here bioengineering
at MIT she's also going to share with us
some of the really fascinating work in
tissue engineering
I've been giving a lot of talks at MIT
in the past year mainly about our new
education program and and it's really
wonderful to be able to share with you
some of the research that drove a lot of
faculty at mighty to try to create the
kind of student who could push these
research frontiers forward
I'd like to acknowledge at the beginning
before I start the research talk the
wonderful support we've gotten from the
Alumni Association in helping develop
our curriculum we several of the faculty
received a class of 1960 teaching award
for some of the very early ideas that we
had in moving toward this kind of
program that would bring biology and
engineering together and it allowed us
to work with students a lot more
effectively and we're very very grateful
for that that support for the education
program what I'd like to do in
describing a little view of the field of
tissue engineering today is give you two
sort of vignettes one is where the field
is going in terms of what we classically
think of of tissue engineering in
building organs and tissues to treat
patients and so that's the
bench-to-bedside part of the talk and
the second part of the talk I want to
give you a glimpse into what may seem
like a more mundane but ultimately I
think is a far more powerful application
of tissue engineering and that's coming
back to the bench and using tissue
engineering for a range of applications
and drug development that will hopefully
help us put all the surgeons who do
organ transplants out of business
someday
except for course my postdoc mentor so -
so to get us oriented let's think about
the what generated enormous excitement
in the field starting at almost a couple
of decades ago now and I call this
tissue engineering version one a common
paradigm in the field is that we have
some kind of source of cells that might
be used to regrow a tissue and in this
case we could imagine a patient who's
lost the outer part of their ear could
have some cells taken from their rib
cartilage if only we could grow them
into the proper shape to put in the
patient so this is just an example of
how you might do that make a scaffold
that's made of a porous bio
a gradable polymer actually common
surgical polymer combine it with cells
and here this is a demonstration that
you can implant this kind of cell
polymer scaffold beneath the skin and
have the tissue grow from the cells that
were implanted onto the polymer this was
an experiment done using a mouse model
and you can see the shape of the human
ear growing on the back of this mouth
after a couple of months and so this
kind of application generated lots of
excitement because it actually works and
it works fairly well and so these kinds
of things are now moving into the clinic
we can ask the question to know if it
works for an application like that which
is fairly constrained in the number of
patients will it work for applications
where there are lots of patients and
more serious problems so the answer
happily is yes
this shows a radiograph from the patient
of one of my collaborators towards
Marshall at the Cleveland Clinic this
patient has a very large tumor in his
bone you can see the diffuse area here
is a cancer of the bone and it needs to
be removed so what will happen in a
patient like this had happened in this
patient typically is this part of the
bone gets cut out and what's done right
now is because it's a very large defect
in the bone a Kadapa piece of cadaver
bone will be placed there in order to
give the patient support following the
surgery well we all can imagine that
cadaver bone doesn't heal so well there
are potential problems with infection
it's not quite the same as having the
real bone another application area what
you that some of you may be facing
arises from injuries to joints you can
see perhaps pretty clearly that this
soccer player here is experiencing an
injury that will later lead to great
problems with his joint and in fact
people who experience injuries like this
and even lesser ones will go on often to
develop osteoarthritis that's a wearing
away of the surface of the the cartilage
that lines the joint in this case in the
knee and osteoarthritis is a leading
cause for hip implants so my my mother
also just had a hip implant
and it was due to the wearing away the
cartilage in her knee so wouldn't it be
better than having a joint replacement
that goes on to lead to complications
later and never works perfectly as the
original joint wouldn't it be better if
we could somehow repair this lesion and
grow cartilage back and have it secured
firmly to the underlying bone just as it
is in the normal tissue so one of the
great areas of activity at MIT and my
lab and many others is trying to combine
these concepts of understanding the
facets that govern cell behavior the
underlying molecular mechanisms that
cause cells to migrate into a wound bed
and cause say stem cells that are
present there to proliferate and turn
into bone or turn into cartilage we're
trying now to combine these factors that
govern the molecular the molecular
factors that govern the properties of
cells with engineering approaches that
would create environments that cells
could be transplanted into these sites
and go on to form new tissues so in work
in our lab we said okay what we really
need are two aspects of this we need to
be able to build a large scaffold that
would be sort of like the house that
these cells would live in and at the
same time we need to be able to give
those cells cues for what they should be
doing when we put them in an implant
site so a common situation in the clinic
is an orthopedic surgeon would have
available if he's doing a joint replace
or wants to repair a joint or repair a
bone he can harvest bone marrow from
that patient and the bone marrow has in
it stem cells that can go on to form
bone so we ask the question can we build
a scaffold that will help those cells go
on to form bone and so let me just take
you through one part of solving this
problem in order to build a device that
could be used to put the cells on we had
to invent a whole new way to process
materials that would be appropriate for
implanting into people and so when I
started out doing this materials
processing wasn't my particular area of
strength I knew a lot about the cells
and how to design polymer
to interact with cells but making those
into a big device wasn't something that
I was that talented at so it turns out
is MIT as we all know as a place where
you run into people all the time from
different disciplines I ran into a
mechanical engineer who had invented a
process called three-dimensional
printing and he had invented it to do
rapid prototyping of airplane engine
parts essentially so what we decided to
do together is say gee when you're
making airplane engine parts you need to
make complicated shapes you need to
build them from some kind of computer
model it sounds like that's the same
kind of challenge we face in building
scaffolds for bone regeneration we might
want to start with an MRI image of a
patient's jaw for example build a new
jaw just exactly to match the other half
of the patient's jaw so can we take a
process that's computer-controlled and
that builds complex three-dimensional
objects up from scratch can we take that
and adapt it to tissue engineering so
starting about ten years ago this is
exactly what we did so we could start
with an idea saying okay we have a
computer model for what we want to build
we want to build a scaffold that has
lots of pores and channels that will
facilitate tissue ingrowth
and we want to build it in a particular
shape okay and the way that we can do
that is to build it up as a series of
very thin two-dimensional layers step by
steps so the three-dimensional printing
process is one of many kinds of
manufacturing and prototyping processes
that are now endemic in many areas that
are called solid freeform fabrication
methods they build up complex objects as
a series of thin two-dimensional slices
so you start in this case by spreading a
powder of an object of the material you
want to build an object from in our case
a biomaterial you spread a powder on to
top of the piston and so you just roll
out a very thin layer of powder into
that powder you print using a computer
model of what you want to build you
print the binder or glue that holds the
powder particles together everywhere you
want a solid part of the object to be
formed and so then you can build many
many devices at once you drop the piston
and you finish printing you drop the
piston down and that gives you the
chance then to roll out another layer of
powder so one of the this has now been
licensing is being commercialized
there's actually some early-stage bone
regeneration products and patients now
but some of the frontiers are actually
solving those extreme challenges such as
joint repair so farik's one of the
companies that licenses that technology
teamed up with a tissue engineering
company advanced tissue Sciences to
design and test a scaffold for joint
repair that takes into account the
number of challenges you have in
building a complex scaffold that will
allow a region to have both bone grow
and to have cartilage grows so the idea
here is that we can at the top part of
the scaffold build a region that will
favour the seating of cartilage cells
into the scaffold and their growth into
cartilage tissue and we can do that by
arranging the pores and channels in a
way that let the cartilage cells easily
get seated in here and then we can
create a second region that has
different materials and different
structure that facilitates the end
growth of bone so you can take these in
the laminates quite straightforward
actually to build these and this shows
shows a joint in this case this was done
in sheep as a test for how this process
would work so the scaffold was seated in
culture with cartilage cells implanted
into the joint and you could later see
that the cartilage formed in vitro and
allowed the joint to move so these sorts
of applications where we combine cells
and scaffolds are really moving into the
clinic now in somewhat incremental ways
but you're still you're starting to see
them appear in applications particularly
in orthopedics and in places where we
have connective tissue repair that are
needed but you can imagine with the
power of combining cells and scaffolds
what if we could build organs that would
replace much more life-threatening
functions so if we can do this for
tissues like bone and cartilage could we
do it for diseases that are truly
life-threatening so you could ask a
question
gee we have an incredible shortage of
organs for heart transplants for liver
transplants for kidney transplants can
we take the same concept and maybe take
one donor organ one liver and use it to
cure a hundred patients who need an
organ transplant could we do that by
taking a tissue engineering approach and
taking the cells from one donor organ
and constructing a whole series of
smaller organs that could be
transplanted into patients so many
people in the field have had a vision
that since liver is such an amazingly
regenerative organ I think some of you
may remember from your high school
mythology class the story of Prometheus
and he stole fire from the God so he got
chained to the rocks and the Eagle would
come every day and eat his liver out and
then it would grow back overnight and
the whole process would repeat the next
day so even long ago it was known that
liber regenerates so all we need is the
Eagle to come and have Prometheus
chained to the rock and we can solve the
organ transplant problem well maybe not
know but that that makes people think
with especially transplant surgeons who
see organs grow back after you excise a
tumor they ask the question could you
then say okay maybe we could get
regeneration and culture if we had a
very complex scaffold that would let
cells assemble into liver like structure
with an artery and a vein maybe what we
could do is take one organ and make a
bunch of mini organs that we could then
transplant into patients and so this
captured the imagination of a lot of
people and then it's something that I
think is still envisioned as possibly
one day coming to fruition but that one
day is pretty far in the future I think
saying ten years is incredibly
optimistic 20 years is optimistic and
it's you know keeping the attention of
NIH and so forth to fund this kind of
research for that long may be the
biggest challenge so we can take a step
back and say gee where will we be in a
couple of decades with this kind of
organ replacement an option one and one
that certainly gets the attention of
popular press is that we're going to be
able to have more or
transplants so all those people now who
died because they don't get a transplant
will be able to get liver in a box you
know hopefully it won't be made in my
lab but my MIT isn't a good
manufacturing process approved place I
don't think but but the idea is that you
would have these organs available for
transplants so that's one option and one
that I think a lot of people get excited
about it would certainly be very
dramatic you get brought back from the
brink of death by ordering your liver
off of livers calm or whatever and there
it is
made just for you option two doesn't
give the press to have so many dramatic
life saving stories option two is that
we just get rid of transplants all
together and maybe only do them under
unusual circumstances so that we put all
those organ transplant surgeons out of
work and now they get to do other things
like golf or whatever they would maybe
be doing if they had more time so we
could ask ourselves you know I actually
see a show hands who would prefer option
one if you're the patient okay option
two that we cure the disease much
earlier so people actually never even
maybe have to go to the hospital they
may go to their doctor get diagnosed and
take a drug and be able to cure the
disease that would ultimately lead to
the organ transplant so we can ask what
are the bottlenecks in realizing option
two why aren't we there with more
diseases and more organs and I'll say
that my own epiphany about this vision
of white-white why aren't we pursuing
option two harder was really brought
about by the creation and biological
engineering division in fact several
faculty who became an integral part of
the division were focused on the area of
toxicology and when we think about
toxicology a lot of us want to maybe
yawn I certainly felt that way initially
but then there was the aha moment
preventing things is much better than
fixing them later on when they're much
more serious and so we really started to
take a hard look at what it was that
prevented us from going and preventing
diseases we certainly do have a lot of
disease models
that we use very very productively to
understand and help develop treatments
for human disease so bob horvitz an MIT
won the nobel prize in part for showing
that C elegans a nematode worm could be
used to understand some facets of cancer
to understand how cells undergo
programmed cell death and we certainly
can use yeast to understand aspects of
our own biology mice and all of these
animals here can reveal different facets
of human disease and help us enormous
Lee in developing therapies and cures
for these diseases but despite the
utility of all these models we know that
mice are not little people worms are
certainly not little people mice are not
little people and even chimpanzees and
orangutangs are not people and what we
would be really excited to have if
you're excited the we being perhaps a
drug company is a model of a human that
could be used to really understand a
complex disease or use to predict how a
human will respond to a drug so we can
do pretty good right now in looking at
the individual molecular interactions
that govern the cell behavior as Doug
described earlier we're starting to put
together the molecular interactions that
transmit signals from outside the cell
to inside the cell that govern gene
regulation for example and we're
somewhat good at understanding how
different cell types interact with each
other to create a more complex response
but as we get up to the tissue level and
certainly the Oregon level humans start
to diverge enormous lis from animals and
how they respond in most cases what we
would love to do is have readily
accessible models therefore of how human
cells and tissues interact to come up
with a complex response so about seven
years ago we started to really refocus
efforts in our lab toward this goal we
still continue to develop some exciting
approaches in treating connective tissue
diseases by tissue engineering but we
decided that trying to build models of
humans so that we could study disease
and hopefully cure it would be an
enormous contribution to the ultimately
to healthcare
and certainly liver probably exemplifies
the need for this approach more than any
other organ so you I don't know an
interview who know anyone who has
hepatitis C it turns out hepatitis C was
discovered around the same time as AIDS
but there really aren't great therapies
for hepatitis C right now there are
therapies and there's some new ones
coming out but it's been incredibly hard
to study this disease because it only
affects humans and chimps and it targets
liver cells and it turns out that when
you take liver cells out and put them in
culture they become refractory to
infection by hepatitis C so you can't
really study the whole viral life cycle
and culture and guess what hepatitis C
is the single leading cause of liver
transplants in the Western world so if
you eliminate it hepatitis C you would
have a lot more organs available for
other people who need transplants and in
fact if you take this approach and say
gee what are some of the other causes of
transplants well there's toxicity of
drugs even tylenol kills about a hundred
people a year in the US and right now
one of the leading causes for drugs to
fail and Phase one clinical trials is
liver toxicity very difficult to predict
liver toxicity because human livers
metabolize drugs in most cases different
than animals you use to test those drugs
okay so there are all of these problems
that we face for which there are no
really good accessible models to study
the human condition and so why is that
we know we can take cells out and put
them in culture and get them to behave
in some cases like they do in the body
and so with liver we can do that we can
take liver tissue dissociate it down
into the individual cells and put them
in culture and get them to look very
beautiful so this is just an example if
we take in our lab we use rats for these
kinds of studies because they're
commonly used in toxicology so we can
isolate the cells from a rat liver by
digesting it with enzymes and put it in
something that makes it think that it's
a little bit that it's like it's back in
the body we use an extracellular matrix
and then we can take a picture of these
cells a couple of days after they're
and culture and they look very beautiful
their nuclei are very round they have a
cytoskeleton organized and they look
quite happy but looks are deceiving when
we go in and start to measure the level
of functions that those cells have that
our liver specific it turns out they
really aren't acting like liver anymore
so this just illustrates that so those
same cells I just showed you if we go in
now and take and break them open and get
their message RNA out and do a
microarray array analysis to look at all
the levels of all there of most of their
genes using a microarray experiment we
see that the cells are losing function
quickly so let me orient you so this is
a scale that everything above the line
means that the gene expression level has
gone up everything below the line means
that it's gone down relative to liver in
the body and this is over a few days and
culture so what you can see here is
we're looking at the genes involved in
drug metabolism so there's about a
hundred or so of these probes on this
particular microarray chip and what's
really obvious is that really soon after
cells are placed in culture they lose
their liver specific gene expression and
this is what bedevils the efforts of the
drug industry to do a better job
predicting toxicology its loss of these
kinds of genes that the devil our
efforts to culture hepatitis and culture
and to study many facets of liver
disease so what can we do we ask the
question can we recapitulate function of
liver by recapitulating the structure of
liver instead of doing a 2d cell culture
maybe what we should be doing is trying
to create environment and culture
through tissue engineering that really
replicates this 3d microscopic
environment so for example this is the
liver capillary bed it's the business
end of the liver it's about half a
millimeter across and in that little
environment hepatocyte s-- the cells
that carry out most of the functions of
liver are in constant communication with
other cells and in fact there are
mechanical forces on these cells arising
from flow of blood that give rise to
signals that tell the cells yes you're
in the right place keep doing all the
things that liver does and in fact David
Darnell won a special Lasker Award for
knowing that when you take cells out of
this environment they lose their message
level and all the things that make them
like liver so I'm gonna fast-forward
through all the development we did to
come up with a design for how we could
create this three-dimensional structure
and show you what we're doing now in our
efforts to build essentially liver on a
chip and use it for a number of
applications so what we reasoned is that
if we could create a little micro
environment that would give the cells
some cues they could organize themselves
into a capillary bed like structure and
it turns out using silicon micro
fabrication technology was a very rapid
route to doing that we have a wonderful
Microsystems technology lab at MIT that
lets you prototype different designs so
we went over there and in a period of
about three years with a lot of support
from DARPA who is interested in using
little livers to detect virus to viruses
that may be warfare agents what we did
is we we came up with a design based on
silicon chip technology that would
foster the formation of
three-dimensional tissue structure from
isolated liver cells so what you see
here is a chip that hasn't it bored into
it a whole bunch of holes so this chip
is about two tenths of a millimeter
thick and when we take we bore holes in
it and then into those holes we see
liver cells and the dimension here is
three tenths of a millimeter and so what
happens is the liver cells attach to the
walls of the holes in the chip now we've
modified the walls of the holes in this
chip with molecules that the liver cells
recognize and they form these tissue
like structures the structures are
stained in green and that actually
indicates the cells are healthy and
viable and so what you see is formation
of tissue like structures that happens
very rapidly and then the tissue appears
stable over time the whole thing lives
in a bioreactor so we place that chip
the scaffold with the cells in here and
then we can flow fluid through the whole
system so you can see a set of pumps
here that are pumping fluid through and
we essentially have liver on a chip now
this kind of this kind of arrangement
allows the cells to capture features of
what liver architecture looks like so
you can see vessel
here endothelial and in fact we can
follow this using what's called
two-photon microscopy that lets us
optically section throughout the tissue
so what we're seeing here is sequential
sections through the tissue over ten
days and what's labeled here are just
the blood vessel lining cells the blood
vessel lining cells are green against
the rest of the cells aren't labeled you
can see that over a period of a couple
of weeks they're forming vessel
structures within this chip so that we
truly are creating three-dimensional
tissue that could be used for a lot of
applications okay so now we've got this
tissue and we've gone through a lot of
different kinds of assays to show that
it has a very high level of function
what can we use it for well one for one
thing we can use it to try to predict
drug toxicity and in what Doug Laughlin
Berger didn't show on his campus changes
were the things associated with the MIT
campus changes Novartis research
headquarters Pfizer Research Technology
Center all these pharmaceutical
companies are looking to MIT for new
methods that can help with drug
development and in fact one of the huge
applications of this is to build little
livers that could be used in
high-throughput screening of new drugs
one other application or there are a
number of applications listed here I'm
just going to show you briefly some
results from one that we're working on
in the biotechnology process engineering
Center and that is this issue of why
gene therapy hasn't quite panned out as
much as everyone hoped about ten years
ago there was a little over five years
ago a very significant event in the
whole field of gene therapy and that was
the death of a patient just Jessie gal
senior at the University of Pennsylvania
he was undergoing a trial to correct a
genetic defect in liver and he died from
the effects of the gene therapy vector
which happened to be an adenovirus so
one of the huge challenges in predicting
how well these kinds of gene therapy
vectors work is that what you see in a
2d culture then doesn't get replicated
in animals very huge differences between
what you see in mice and what you see in
cell culture when you're designing these
vectors and then huge differences
between what you see in a mouse and what
you
see in a person when you go to use it
clinically so we can now use this new
tool of a three-dimensional liver to
start asking questions on why these kind
of gene therapy vectors are toxic and
try to build in safeguards against that
and address those as we design new
vectors so just as an example we can use
the classic adenoviral vector in fact
this was is a vector we get from the
University of Pennsylvania and monitor
the whole process in a model way by
having cells express a green fluorescent
protein so just to give you an idea of
how this pans out we can measure many
many things about how these gene therapy
vectors interact with real 3d tissues in
this new system so here we're showing a
3d reconstruction of a single capillary
bed in our little unit so again the
dimensions here about three tenths of a
millimeter and this is stained it's a 3d
reconstructed image from optical
sectioning so we've stained it so that
cells expressing the gene that we've
transfected in or green so these cells
have taken up the gene are expressing it
all of the cells are staying blue and
cells that have been killed or stained
red so now we can start to build
quantitative models of how how we should
design gene therapy vectors to be
effective and actually also safe and
we're working with a lot of other people
in that project
another application area that is hugely
challenging is understanding how to stop
cells at the very earliest stages of
tumor metastasis so often we can't see a
metastasis until it's about a centimeter
in diameter the resolution methods are
getting better but what we really would
love to do is figure out if you remove a
primary tumor how do you keep the cells
that have moved to distant organs and
our single cells invading the tissue
from growing in to larger tumors so we
can use this little micro reactor system
because we control the fluid flow
locally we can build a model of how that
tumor cell actually grows into a tumor
and we can watch the whole thing as it
happens so this is just an example of
putting prostate tumor cells into the
liver and so this is the silicon chip
this is the tissue and you can just kind
of see it there and if we look a couple
of week
later we've just put a few tumour cells
in they've grown into large tumors that
we can see you can actually see them
with your naked eye these little white
areas or tumors and they've been growing
very large because there's fluid flow
through controlled at the microscale
level and so I'll finish up here just
showing this is again imaging to show
the tumor taking over the liver starts
out as green and you can see the tumor
taking over in a period of a couple of
weeks the tumor is red in this case and
it's being invaded by connective tissue
from the underlying cells so all of this
is great we do I have a lot of graduate
students in the lab who are working very
hard with our prototype system but
clearly what we need if we're going to
move this into high-throughput assays is
to adapt this design in these design
concepts into a high-throughput format
so we're working with the local
pharmaceutical company to do exactly
that and figure out how we can take this
sort of concept and put it in a multi
well plate format and this little movie
just shows you how we can use micro
fluidics now to replace that whole big
reactor system now we've crunched it
down actually this plate has 24 little
reactors this one's got 5 and you can
see the fluid being pumped through here
using microfluidics
and so we're trying to move this now out
of the lab and actually have people use
it so that we can have physiological
models of humans and actually put those
transplant surgeons out of business and
even though it's not as exciting for the
news media what we hope is that we'll be
able to develop drugs better and faster
and cure diseases that right now we
really don't have a great handle on so
the parting thoughts are that two big
messages there are some great
applications of tissue engineering
moving into the clinic they mostly have
to do with connective tissues there's
very hard to move into the go from
animals up to people but that the big
future of tissue engineering though it's
a lot sounds a lot more mundane not
quite as scintillating is actually to
have a human body on a chip so that we
can ultimately predict how humans will
respond and cure diseases so with that
I'll close and I'll talk to you at the
panel discussion
[Applause]
let's see I've used I've used Wow
so I guess I'll go for spectacular this
time just a terrific terrific stuff you
guys having fun yeah this is neat neat
stuff professor Angela Belcher is up up
next
now Angela the last fall it's one of mi
t--'s newest MacArthur Foundation genius
grant recipients pretty exciting news
delighted to share that with you this
morning and she's going to spend some
time with us now as she's working to
develop materials on a nano scale and
how she's using nature as a guy Angela
[Applause]
well thank you very much I really
appreciate the invitation to come here
and speak to you today and tell you a
little bit about what we're thinking
about at the biological engineering
interphase and as Professor Lawson
Berger said in the in the first talk
that this is a relatively new discipline
so I came to MIT because I I thought
this is the place where it's all going
to happen and it's a really exciting
place to be but one thing that I think
is a little bit different is that I
think that biological engineering has
been around for quite a long time and I
brought an example with me today this is
an abalone shell that was a marine
gastropod that was grown off the coast
of Santa Barbara this is an organism
that has an incredible ability to make
materials at the nano scale what it does
is it it uses materials from its
environment it uses the the chemicals it
has in the ocean to build this really
exquisite structure the structure is
very very tough and very strong it's
3,000 times tougher than its geological
counterpart I didn't tell you it's made
out of calcium carbonate which is
basically chalk but the organism figured
out how to make it in a way that was
incredibly strong the organism also
figured out a way to make it and using
non-toxic processing and so I think that
one of the keys is to look at nature and
how nature is constructed materials over
millions of years and see what we can
learn from that and what can we apply it
to what we like to say nature hasn't had
the opportunity to work with yet during
that the the Cambrian pre-pre cambium
geological time period when the the ions
in the ocean the chemicals in the ocean
started changing the organisms had to
learn how to deal with these the changes
and the chemicals in the ocean and being
clever they actually decided to use it
to to make materials so the kinds of
materials that Nature has worked with
they're really limited to what's found
in the ocean and we'll talk about that
today these this structure also was
built based on on millions of years of
evolution we at MIT the the lifespan of
a graduate student is about four to five
years and so we have to figure out how
to develop materials on the time scale
not you
logical timescale but the time scale of
an MIT graduate student so starting with
that I want to show my really incredible
group that I have a at at MIT this is a
really multidisciplinary group we have
students from biological engineering
biology chemistry Chemical Engineering
material science and engineering and
electrical engineering and physics we're
all working together to see if we can
understand how nature makes materials
and convince organisms to work with
materials that they haven't already
worked with before so about a year ago I
was asked by the National nanoscience
initiative to say well I thought the
biggest challenges in material science
were today and I took this very
seriously and so I put together a list
of what what I thought the biggest
challenges were maybe we can actually
make that fit a little better I said I
like a material that it can actually
self assemble I like a material bit
self-correcting so if you have a
computer component and it breaks it can
fix itself or self-healing I like to
have a material that can grow its own
template that can recycle its own
template it only goes to a desired
length in diameter and then stops I'll
show you a little bit about how a
Bologna's shells grow but the abalone
shell the structure that makes this so
exquisite and makes this color I can you
can come see it afterwards this color so
beautiful this is the same color of
pearls is that the thickness of this
inorganic material the thickness of this
chalk is controlled at the genetic level
to be precise and that precise control
gives it many wonderful properties so
I'd also like to have a material that's
environmentally benign and uses
environment I'm precocious and solvents
be great to have a material that is
grown at room temperature and pressure
that generates little waste the
organisms in the ocean they don't
produce a lot of toxic waste because
that would be you know bad for the
organisms we'd like to span multiple
linked scales for the most part I'm a
self-assembling self organizing material
that is it's organized from the
nanoscale to the the macro length scale
so we'd like to be able to take those
kinds of properties and be able to apply
to other kinds of materials interface
organic and inter-gang interfaces
interface with biology but my dream is
to have a material that's genetically
controllable and genetically tunable I'd
like to have a DNA sequence that codes
for the production of any kind of
material you want you want a solar cell
here's the DNA sequence for it you want
a battery here's the DNA sequence for it
I'd also like one that's responsible to
external cues inexpensive of course and
scalable so it's a pretty long list and
your response is appropriate response
but at the same time biology has already
figured out how to master many of these
properties and so us as material
scientists and biological engineers we
think it's our job to figure out how
they solve these problems and guide them
to work on other problems and so what
we'd like to do is order with genetic
control the atomic scale to the
macroscopic scale to where we can
control atoms and unit cells and
lattices to basically self assemble
devices and I'll show you a couple
devices today I'll show you the first
virus assembled nano electrode I'll show
you the first virus assembled
rechargeable battery as two examples so
as I said before biologies already
figured out how to do a lot of this they
can communicate with innocent in a Cell
they can correct themselves they have
genetic code which codes for the
synthesis of everything they need this
is a eukaryotic cell and this is a
prokaryotic cell we'd like to have the
same kind of properties the way that
we're gonna do this is we're gonna
actually evolved organisms to work with
materials we wanted to work with we're
gonna force organisms to live with
semiconductor materials and force them
to live with electronic materials so
that they can start to use them and
process them but that's pretty
challenging when you think about
biological organisms which are soft and
they're in aqueous conditions they're in
water and they're basically squishy
organisms how are you gonna think about
integrated into a semiconductor fab line
or something that that's that's done at
a really controlled atmospheric
conditions
so there's robustness questions how
robust is it
you can you um you have to to work with
the conditions under which organisms
normally live and then if you want to
evolve these organisms how far can you
push them and where do you start when we
first started thinking about this
problem we thought about antibodies
which are natural proteins in the body
that bind small molecules these small
molecules could be organic molecules or
they could be other proteins and they do
it with an incredible amount of
specificity so these proteins that that
in your body can recognize you know
addition of a carbon to a molecule or
they can recognize chirality of a
molecule we said we want that we want a
protein that can recognize an electronic
component that can recognize a unit cell
of an inorganic material here's another
I never really knew snowflakes until I
moved to to New England but this is an
incredible self-assembling system you
think of this really exquisite structure
and in the middle it has a nucleus that
allows for the nucleation of this really
complex structure really exquisite
structure so what we'd like to do is
have a nucleus that that codes for or
tells an electronic component how to
grow this is a slide that that talks
about about scale and so we're
interested in in nano scale and I had a
reporter asked me yesterday did you
always know you wanted to be a
nanotechnologist and and you know I I
can tell you that I haven't thought a
day about it what what I thought was
biology makes incredible materials what
what linked scale does biology choose to
grow materials but for the most part it
chooses Nana it chooses the nano scale
so it's worked well for biology let's
see if we can harness that and so here's
it this is a length of a typical
component here of a piece of your inside
of your computer now here's a drawing a
schematic link scale of certain
biological molecules and so this is a
DNA strand here this is a ribosome it's
a
a molecular machine that processes all
the proteins in your body and here's
some other kinds of proteins as well so
we said if you want to make things small
why don't you start with building blocks
of biological molecules that can process
these again the fact that there's these
already naturally existing molecular
machines that evolved to be be very
specific this is a diagram of what a
ribosome looks like basically a the the
biological machine that reads messenger
RNA and and builds proteins we said
wouldn't it be great if as it's going
along and reading its are its messenger
RNA instead of building a protein why
don't you have it build a semiconductor
you know is that possible can you have
each tRNA molecule that is specific for
a amino acid have a codon that's
specific for electronic material and
we've recently accomplished that in
relatively small way in the lab this
year well there's many kinds of
naturally occurring biomaterials this is
a cockle at the forehead it's a
unicellular algae that's made out of
calcium carbonate this is an abalone
shell like the one that I showed before
this is a fracture of an abalone shell
and looking at it in scanning electron
micrograph you can see these tablets
which were basically chalk tablets but
they stack on top of each other to form
this brick wall like structure no
proteins that are coated at the DNA
level decide what kind of material to
grow what thermodynamic phase of this
material to grow how thick it is and how
it stacks up to make this really tough
structure this is a diatom it's made out
of all show you a little bit more about
it's basically made out of glass and
these are magnetotactic bacteria which
have inside of them small single domain
magnets which are used for navigation
they make these really incredible
magnets now all of these are processed
in the ocean basically at ocean
temperatures using non-toxic materials
and and pressures in the ocean so what's
the key how does this work
well this is an this is a mantle
epithelial basically epithelial tissue
from the abalone shell and abalone is a
gastropod it basically has a big foot
and a big piece of tissue that comes
across here these cells are the cells
that are pushed right up against the
abalone shell and their job is to
secrete proteins and discrete ions it
actually builds the shell so in between
this tissue and the shell is basically a
little reaction vessel that grows grows
the shell and the key is is that these
there's proteins in these cells that are
pumped out into the space that guide the
growth of the inorganic materials here's
a diagram of how it works
proteins are made out of amino acids
amino acids differ from each other based
on chemical functionality these
particular proteins that are very
negatively charged and their job is to
grab calcium ions out of solution out of
the ocean and and start to use them to
build structures and so they do this in
a very exquisite way the distance
between the negative charges is very
important it causes the distances
between the the inorganic material the
chalk basically it causes to grow up in
this particular way this is just showing
some more kind of pictures this is the
abalone shell here these are individual
tablets this is the top this is actually
a part of a pearl that that it looks
like it hasn't grown out to its full
length but this was an organic component
this is the protein that actually
directs it and helps it grow these kinds
of materials and this is a mechanism
basically you have these proteins in
solution they're binding calcium binding
calcium carbonate starting to build
these these nanostructured materials
start to grow up to be a full shell or a
full pearl and this is just kind of a
fun picture because this down here is
the the older shell and this is the new
components that are just growing and
haven't grown out to their full length
yet these are diatoms made out of silica
this is a scanning electron micrograph
and this is on the micron scale but the
reason I show you this is that diatoms
are there's at least 10,000 different
species of diatoms and they're the
they're classified based on their
morphology and you can see how different
this morphology is these are made out of
glass but there's there all this their
different species and so what it says
they also have all
reaction vessel which is the ocean so it
says that this overall macroscopic
structure of these organisms is coded at
the DNA level so if you look at the
kinds of here's this periodic table if
you if you look at the kinds of elements
that nature has to work with it mostly
is calcium the form of calcium carbonate
like shells it has calcium phosphate
like like bones it has a silicon that I
showed you for silica and it has has
iron but what about the rest of the
periodic table why hasn't nature use the
whole periodic table to build materials
out of you know the answer to that in
our group is it just haven't had the
opportunity yet let's give the organisms
opportunity to work in this part of the
periodic table let's let's give them the
opportunity to make semiconductors let's
give them the opportunity to make
materials for magnetic storage and
materials for batteries so let's take
the idea of protein-protein interaction
or protein and antibody interaction and
let's combine it with fabrication to
make what we called evolved hybrid
materials and the question is is how are
you going to think about doing that if
you you know we can take proteins from
the shell and we can extract them out
and we can start making synthetic shell
and in the lab but how do you figure out
what sequences to use to to grow a
semiconductor okay so we don't have any
data for that you could probably do
modeling but professor Lofton Berger
says you know they don't use a lot of
trial and error we actually use sorry we
use a lot a lot of trial and error to
begin with and then we take what we
learned from that and then we try to
make it better and so we didn't know how
to come up with these sequences so we
decided to borrow an idea from the drug
discovery industry that's called phage
display which uses a virus this is a
virus that is a non-toxic virus it
actually has a bacterial host as a
material scientist I look at this as an
object that's about one micron long in
this direction and about six six
nanometers across in this direction and
it only has a couple of of genes that
cut the code for a couple of proteins so
it's actually easy to manipulate
we can put we can do additions in the
DNA sequence that code for additions in
the in the protein on one into the virus
why we want to do this well we want to
take a billion possibility
simultaneously as a library we want to
search through this library to see if we
can find any chemical groups on on the
protein that match the semiconductor of
interest okay
just like the abalone shell found a way
to grow calcium carbonate we want to use
a virus because it's quick and easy and
takes only a couple of weeks to go
through this whole process and use this
in our lab so here's the idea the idea
is now you have a library of viruses
that are all genetically identical to
each other they only differ from each
other based on a small amino acid
protein on a small protein on each end
now in about a one microliter sample you
can have a billion different viruses and
you can force them to interact with a
semiconductor wafer most of them won't
have any chemical specificity and you
wash those off some will have a chemical
specificity and you want to keep those
no they can't make copies of themselves
and so you have to infect them into the
bacterial host which now acts as a
factory and makes a million copies for
you and now you have a population of
these proteins that have some affinity
for the surface now we think of this as
kind of a Darwinian process we want to
take that population and force them to
interact again and go through this
process about five to seven times
looking for the survival of the fittest
the one that works best with a
semiconductor and here's a movie that my
students made that was on MSNBC where
you have this population of viruses and
you're throwing it out a semiconductor
and you're looking for the ones that
have a chemical functionality that
matches the material most of them don't
Mayer washed away this is also done to
music but I didn't even play the music
and then you can manipulate and change
the the the surface charge on these and
remove them from the surface and then
you can infect them into their bacterial
host the bacteria now makes a million
copies for you and then gives them back
again and so this is our amplification
so now we've worked with about 40
different kinds of materials in my group
and
and it takes about two to three weeks to
get to the answer get to the sequence
that you can control the material so we
look at a virus as just a material that
has that has DNA that's easy to
manipulate that you can actually change
the DNA and change the coat of the virus
the major major protein coat of the
virus to to have it be specific for
anything you want it to be specific for
here's a list of the kinds of materials
we've worked with in my group these are
these are semiconductor materials over
here that we're looking at for laser
technology right now we're really
interested in in gallium nitride a laser
material that that might be a very
efficient material for solar cells we've
worked in this part of the periodic
table here from magnetic storage I'll
show you some materials over here that
we're using to make rechargeable
batteries and over here that we're using
to make nano electrodes so this is just
a this is the real data this is an
example of how you can select a virus to
be specific for something like like a
gallium arsenide a semiconductor wafer
what we did was through this process of
throwing the viruses at the material and
asking the deveined and getting rid of
the ones that weren't specific we came
up with some that bound this material
gallium arsenide which is a
semiconductor material that that
biological organisms would have never
had to come in contact with and learn to
live with or or to use and then so this
is a gallium arsenide wafer when these
are 1 micron lines with 4 micron spaces
and we basically use these these these
viruses it's just a tag - we put a
organic molecule dye molecule on it we
dipped our wafer in the in a solution of
the virus and we pulled it out and what
you can see is that it pulled out just
the gallium arsenide it didn't recognize
the material that it wasn't evolved to
recognize well we've been doing that
work was was first published we first
thought about this and in 2000 we
published this what we've got we want to
go down that rest of the list that I
told you so we can get an organism to
work with the material normally
doesn't work with but so what you you
know we want to grow the material we
want to use it for some kind of
important technology and this is work by
a graduate student of mine Asher who had
this very clever idea it was very bold
idea which was we'd already shown that
we can select viruses to be specific for
different kinds of semiconductors but he
said let's select viruses to find
mistakes in semiconductors let's let's
find him to find defects in
semiconductors and so what he did was he
took a population of viruses and forced
them to interact with defects and
semiconductors single atomic defects and
semiconductors and then he negatively
selected them to not recognize non
defects and so then what he does is now
he has a fluorescent signal where you
can you can take a device you can take
away fur and you can dip it in your
virus and it can count the number of
mistakes on that you can optically read
it out which is which is pretty
interesting but we're now we're looking
at applying this to other materials we
do a lot of work with the army we're
looking at applying this to other
materials where you might be able to
find defects and in in instrumentation
in the field so what we want to do is
basically have a solution that you spray
on to something like the wing of an
airplane where the organism a virus or
in this case is a yeast actually sticks
to it and gives out an optical signal so
if you if you're able to have a
biological organism that recognizes a
defect it'll light up and so you can
just spray it on yes there's a defect in
this you need to pull the plane over no
there's not a defect in this you're okay
to deploy so in addition we're looking
at being able to grow things we so we
can tag things we can look for defects
but what if you want to to self assemble
a battery from scratch okay how are you
gonna do that this is some real sequence
this is this is protein sequence that
comes from third round fourth round and
fifth round selection in inter and part
of your evolutionary process and what
you can see these are color coded for
the functional groups what I hope you
can see is that there's a lot of
similarities in the colors of groups but
eventually as you take it through
additional rounds the sequences fall out
they come to what's called a consensus
sequence these are the best sequences to
use
so before we tag the material but we'd
like to grow a material shells do it
bones bones we do it
magnet bacteria do it here's our cartoon
of what it would look like if a virus
could grow for semiconductor particles
on its head this was our idea so our
idea was to have the proteins on the tip
of a virus have a sequence that allows
him to grow a semiconductor and this is
a low resolution TEM image of a virus
that's that's grown a collection of
semiconductor particles called quantum
dots on its head and this is magnified
about 800,000 times showing you the
lattice showing you the atomic levels of
that the atomic structure of that
semiconductor so this is where we used a
virus through genetic engineering and
selection we convinced it to grow five
semiconductor particles on its head so
that I mean that was we thought that was
very interesting but I'm not sure how
practical that is and so we decided to
go back into the genome of the virus and
do more engineering so that now instead
of growing things on just five copies on
one end of the virus let's grow them all
across the length of a virus so let's
make viruses that are electronic
components semiconductors and and in
metal materials that can be used for
wiring up a device and here's a picture
so the idea now is to have the virus act
as a scaffold to to grow lots of little
semiconductor particles along its length
like this picture and I forgot to
mention to you that we lucked out when
we picked this organism to work with
because the the code of the virus the
major body of the virus actually
self-assembles itself okay and itself
assembles itself in a crystalline manner
so that all the proteins are all crystal
graphically related to each other so we
picked we picked a perfect scaffold
already made by Nature and what we say
is now let's manipulate it to do
something we wanted to do let's have it
grow semiconductor wires and this is a
special kind of transmission electron
micrograph this is a one micron scale
bar here of the first virus grown
semiconductor wires this is an element
map that shows you that most of the
wires that the the inorganic material is
a zinc and the sulfur actually map back
to this particular semiconductor so our
idea was that if you could get a virus
to grow lots of different particles and
you could get it do it in high packing
could you then get rid of the the
biological organism and be left with
with nice wires they're all the same
length and all the same Y same diameter
that could be used in electronics and
here's some of our first examples of
those these are very high quality
semiconductor wires that are all grown
based on on the genetic engineering of a
virus this is a 200 nanometer link scale
here we've been doing a lot of further
engineering I'll show you the first
virus based nanotube this is a silver
base nanotube the this part here is all
inorganic material it's all silver this
part here this is where the DNA is in
the virus and the virus actually has the
code to build this this silver wire and
we've been using this this technology
this is worked by a very talented
student of mine Keith am too to see if
you can direct viruses to build a lot of
electrodes for batteries and so this is
going towards the first virus based
battery the thing that we think is good
about this is that we could try to grow
it at room temperature we could try to
use non-toxic materials we could make it
flexible and we think that by adding the
nano scale regularity that that nature
already gives you that we could take
advantage of that and so this was key
taste dream about six months ago and
this is the first virus based lithium
ion rechargeable battery that was made
in our group and this was done with in
collaboration with Professor Paula
Hammond and chemi and professor yet Ming
Chang and in materials so over here you
basically have a flask that has the the
sequences encoded to grow the anode
material the electrode for the battery
you grow it up in the lab you pour in
the pre
the organism grows it you put it on a
surface and we're able to actually reach
the theoretical capacity for energy
density based on this material and it's
all made very rapidly it's made at room
temperature the thing that's really nice
is that the viruses actually
self-organized themselves as well and so
we're looking at this is a flexible high
energy density battery that can be made
very inexpensive we're also looking at
actually integrated in it a textiles we
do a lot of work with Natick soldier
Center which actually tries to make
textiles and better uniforms for for the
soldiers in the field and a good portion
of the the weight of a soldier is
actually batteries and so we're seeing
can we make these flexible batteries
into textiles and weave them into into
the soldiers uniform directly now you
can do other fun things with viruses
like you can engineer the head of a
virus to binder the tail of a virus and
make virus based nano rings that's
mostly just for just for fun and we've
been working on trying to assemble these
into electronic components either nano
electrodes that are self assembling we
want to have a sequence it tells the
electrode tells the electronic component
where to sit what to grow and how to
grow it back in case it gets damaged and
this is a work by um Chang and you wanna
pin trying to figure out new ways of
engineering to have multiple kinds of
functionalities and here are some
examples of the first virus based nano
electrodes growing in our lab we
convinced the virus to buying gold on
this side gold on this side so this is
six nanometers Indra in this direction I
covered up a scale bar but this must be
500 nanometers across and then we pour
it in the solution and the viruses grew
the gold wires these are very small
wires actually which have ohmic contact
and have some reasonable electronic
properties they're definitely not not
perfect yet but the organism has the
ability to grow to bind the material on
this side bind the material on this side
and grow the material in between all
coated at the DNA level this is going
towards our first virus based transistor
where we've we've encoded the organism
to bind to to electro
on each side and then encoded it to bind
a semiconductor in between to connect
these two electrodes so this is a
semiconductor material grown between two
gold electrodes I think I have a few
more minutes here so I've reached some
of those goals that I told you that that
we'd like to be able to do but we have a
we have a long way left to go but the
other thing in picking this organism we
again we were really lucky and the fact
that biology chooses things to be
actually of defined lengths if you have
an enzyme in your body that's too short
if an important part is cleaved off then
it can be non-functional and you could
have a disease well the same thing with
viruses they always build their
structures at the same length and so we
can predict that we know how how they
are but I think it's really nice about
having materials all this at the same
length is that they can assemble
themselves and so think about taking a
box with crayons and you you throw a
couple of crayons in and you shake the
box and they're kind of randomly
oriented relative to each other but the
more you throw in and and keep shaking
it they actually start to self-assemble
well viruses do this too and they
actually make liquid crystals and so in
this case what we've done is we've
engineered our virus to grow a material
of interest and in self-assemble itself
into a liquid crystal for things like
liquid crystal displays and so here's
the movie for that so the idea is
through this genetic selection you've
selected these organisms to be specific
to grow a semiconductor you put in the
precursors just like happens in the
ocean they grow the materials you keep
adding more viruses and they actually
start to assemble themselves into a very
defined structures they line up so virus
semiconductor virus semiconductor virus
semiconductor and they form really
exquisite patterns and if you look at
them in a cross polarized microscopy you
can see that they're actually liquid
crystalline materials the thing that's
really fascinating about these materials
though if you take these liquid crystals
these high concentrations of viruses and
you basically
played him out on a surface they
actually form films this is a this is a
structure that looks like a piece of
tape you can pick it up with your foot
with forceps and it's 99% virus 1%
semiconductor and you can you can pick
it up with forceps and you can move it
around so we look at this as maybe
having materials that are like tape
rolls where you could actually roll out
your electronic materials or roll out
different kinds of materials based on
this ability to to self assemble this is
just showing you you know it's
interesting to think of a virus as a
unit cell and these are the unit cells
that actually stack on top of each other
they have really interesting interesting
structures which will kind of skip over
but you can actually engineer and put
anything you want on I'm a gold enzyme
an organic molecule and have them self
assemble into these these film kind of
structures I just want to introduce one
more idea which is looking to nature
again and thinking about how spiders
spend silk silk silk is a material
that's that's obviously naturally
evolved what happens is that the
organisms that the spiders take a high
concentration of protein and that's
that's a liquid crystal phase and they
push it through a small hole basically
called the spinner rat and they spin out
silk fibers so our idea was well if you
can make liquid crystals out of a lot of
viruses and spiders spin silk out of
liquid crystals maybe we can spend
viruses and we were able to do that
these are viruses that are you can grow
from meters in length that are basically
using the same principles of how how
spiders spend silk but we spend viruses
know we spend viruses that have optical
materials in them and magnetic materials
and semiconductor materials in them so
they could be used for things like
optical fibers we're using them for tags
for integrating it into soldiers
uniforms and we're using them for bio
detectors as well and this shows you
that you can actually make mats out of
them and we're trying to use them for
nonwoven fabrics there's other organisms
you could use - we chose viruses yeast
or incredible materials we like ease
because
we work with professor whit Tripp who's
a yeast expert because we use the same
yeast that you used to make beer and
bread and we try to use them to make
semiconductors and so we you know from
the from the beer industry and that the
beverage industry that yeast are
scalable and so we look at yeast as
factories as a possibility of growing
growing materials and so instead of
Budweiser we think of nano wiser you
know
factories okay so I'm out of time but
I'll leave you with that and I thank you
for your attention
start it up here again thank you for for
working quickly back back to your seats
so you guys still still having fun you
ready for to hear some to more of the
outstanding faculty here at MIT you
can't hear me let's see are we getting
any better with the acoustics now we can
get more volume they're saying they
can't oh there we go
hello okay I think we've got it we're
gonna get going we have two more
presentations and we may be a little bit
late for lunch my my sense of the energy
in the room is that folks will in fact
want to have the panel QA will gauge
that a little bit a little bit later but
I'd like to do is get get moving with
Professor ROM Saskia saccharine
extraordinarily talented researchers
that has has won numerous awards for his
creative ways that he's had some
innovation here in the life sciences
going to talk a little bit about the
emerging field of glycolics
[Applause]
thank you very much I'd like to begin
with saying that it's really a pleasure
and privilege to be here sharing with
you some of our work here at MIT and I'd
like to specifically say that the Alumni
Association is one that I've paid
attention to because one of the past
president of the Alumni Association
Brian Hughes actually did in part
support some of the areas that I'm gonna
briefly touch upon today so I really
know how important it is in terms of how
alumni Steve back to MIT but having said
that the title of my talk today is
glycomics the sweet science I know all
of you took a break right now and you
had some sugar and in this in the
simplest form like omics is the study of
sugars but not the sugars that you are I
think are talking about right now in
terms of the one that you put in your
coffee
now that's the energy level at MIT and
so you know the fascinating thing is
that life has exploited simple sugars in
the most extraordinary way to generate
energy that you and I know the reason
why we take a break and get some carbs
that's not what I'm talking about
because I know there's good and bad
things about carbs it's so it's not the
low carb diet but I'm gonna tell you
about how life systems have actually
exploited carbohydrates going beyond the
energy system in some fundamental ways
that it's been both a challenge in many
ways in terms of the science Doug talked
about the two revolutions the molecular
revolution in the genomic revolution the
field of carbohydrate studying
carbohydrates to understand its place in
biology was a struggle but engineering
in many ways with the help of technology
has sort of demystified that and part of
what I'm going to do today is to share
with you some of those exciting
technological innovations that have
really opened up this field so it's not
about Atkins diet so I'd like to connect
to a point that Doug made earlier which
is much of biology then focused on how
you could look at herself how a cell
regulates variety of cellular processes
and it was driven by the central dogma
the bible of life how the blueprint DNA
makes RNA RNA makes protein and
everything was beautiful at life and
technology in terms of ability to
sequence DNA and proteins and the
recombinant DNA technology that you just
heard Angie Belcher talk about how you
can manipulate DNA to basically create
any kinds of systems that will enable
you to address in a Cell and
historically everything outside the cell
and you heard some of my colleagues
refer to this word extracellular matrix
you very simple terms you can do that as
a junkyard at the back yard of the house
you throw all the garbage you ignore it
sometimes you have somebody come and
take care of it the the outside of the
cell is no different and a large part
what it is made up of is actually these
complex glycans complex carbohydrates
where the simple sugars are taken
further into much higher level of
complexity that i'm going to get to and
in
anyways how the cells perceive its
environment regulates signal so that the
cells now know they need to divide
migrate or die is is controlled by this
extra environment and the biology then
ignored this and many tools that were
developed to study proteins in DNA
actually we're developed in a way that
you could butcher the sugars because
that was the stuff that you wanted to
get rid of because you wanna access
things here things have changed now
we're now into a very exciting area of
how we're trying to take a more systems
or an integrated view it's no longer the
cell in isolation cells are in the
context of this micro environment
there's the cell the extracellular
matrix how the cells come together to
form a tissue so that you have a liver
cell liberty the liver cell that's
coming to the form of liver tissue or
the lung cells coming to form as a lung
tissue in each of these cells that
package themselves in unique in
different ways to give you the property
associated with the tissue and in that
is this very important space the
extracellular environment that brings
these pieces together and the
polysaccharides or the carbohydrates
hydrate this environment so liberalised
variety of signaling molecules that come
from the outside and then send signals
to the cells and in many ways the reason
why we're able to access these things
are through several high put throughput
technologies such as the genomics and
proteomics it's not looking at one
single component it's looking at the
component in a concerted way so that you
can orally understand how a cell behaves
but how the cells behave in the context
of the tissue and the micro environment
to give you the property of the oregon
or the organ system leading to the
organisms and in many ways we did need
the help of genetics the whole organism
genetics once you knocked out a gene or
knocked in a gene to really understand
how that particular gene transmitted
information not only the context of a
cell but all the way into the tissue to
the organism level so as to appreciate
the complexity of biology with regard to
glycomics of the study of sugar this
became a very important piece because
when you knocked out genes that made
these carbohydrates at a single cellular
level you could not really demystify
that we needed whole organism genetics
and what was very interesting
historically is that when people study
it whether it's a fly or a mouse or any
other sort of animal model system that
when they saw some very strange
phenotypes the wings in the wrong place
the eyes in the wrong place are the
wrong kinds of limbs the length of the
limb so on and so forth they eventually
found out that several of the genes that
we're affecting these processes going
beyond the cell into the tissue level
actually we're related to enzymes that
made these sugars made these complex
sugars so in very simple terms the way
I'd look at it as you can view average
every cell that is in our body has a
sugar coat on them it's like the way we
wear jackets and winter we wear a fur
coat or a thick jacket in summer we got
a t-shirt in simple way the way you
could look at how a cell functions is
that the sugar coat on the cell
dramatically influences how the cell
behaves and how the cellular processes
are regulated hence so I want to be able
to go back and put it in the context of
the
so sorry about that so I want to be able
to go back to the molecular picture the
the molecular revolution that dad talked
about and put sugars in context and then
take you through the journey of how it
translates the Camorra complex systems
as I said earlier the dogma was that DNA
made RNA made proteins that truly big
tended the principles of life we now
know that's no longer this the only part
of the story these proteins are
seriously and heavily decorated by these
sugars Arda like ants that dramatically
influence the behavior and the
properties of these proteins so in many
ways what you can get is a huge amount
of functional diversity in terms of this
one gene to one protein and with this
diversity you're able to take a small
set of proteins and get an extraordinary
amount of functional possibilities so if
we take one particular protein system
this is erythropoietin which is actually
a very important biotech drug which is
used for anemic patients this particular
protein has sugars decorated on them so
that one particular protein has greater
than 150 unique sugar structures that
can give you a plethora of biological
properties and part of what we're trying
to do is to truly demystify that
understand how do these distinct sugar
structures on this protein influence
function and therefore get to the heart
of what we call us structure function
relationships so in many ways the dogma
has been revisited because if you truly
get to the G from the genotype to the
phenotype we need to really understand
what are the principles of these sugars
in terms of how they regulate the
functions of these proteins therefore we
can understand biology in the truest
sense so if I were to use one slide to
drive home the point but importance of
black hands it would be this where the
only difference in many ways has been
the kinds of sugars that are displayed
on these cells that I talked about to
just give you an office
I mean opposite phenotype in terms of
the same locus so this is a very
important field as you can see but it
has had its challenges in large part
it's because of the fact that there have
been lack of tools to study these
molecules the point that I made
several the tools that we're developers
actually developed in terms of getting
rid of sugars so in many ways sugars
were a hassle to deal with they were
more this inert material that was
outside the cell probably was by and
large useless but we now know that there
are numerous functions in search of what
I call a structure or sequence after the
relationship and a large part it is
because of the fact that there are these
heterogeneous polydisperse but highly
information content material that has
released immediate and in very simple
terms I can say that B come in two
flavors there are these linear sugars
and the sugars that branch and that
structural diversity truly enables us to
get this very diverse set of functions
that are possible and I'll give you some
specific examples to go through that
another important point to put it in
context with regard to DNA and proteins
is that you can amplify DNA you can act
amplify proteins you saw my colleague
dr. Belcher talk about how you can
basically take a virus and get the
bacteria to copy many numbers but that's
not the case of sugars
you cannot amplify them so what you
isolate them from these cells or tissues
is what you have so you really need
innovation that enables you to access
this kind of low amounts of material and
keep in mind they're not only low
amounts but you have all this poly
dispersed highly complex set of
structures another thing that
complicates the analysis is that unlike
DNA and proteins where there's a
template there's a there's a reading
frame that enables you to make these
copies there are non template complex
biosynthesis a bunch of enzymes come
together and decorate the cells are the
proteins with these sugars so in many
ways it complicates our ability to
understand how some of the structure
activity relationship truly Drive the
biological processes and if I were to
sort of step back and put it in the
context of a broader framework you can
view sugars regulating function in an
analogue fashion that is it's not a
switch of a turn on and off of a light
it's like a rheostat it's like a dimmer
where there's a plethora of structures
that give you a diversity of functions
and when I go through these examples
I'll illustrate what that analog
function means but the important thing
is the fact that with the complexity and
the way they are made
the lack of the
but for biosynthesis you truly need a
more complex sort of a systems approach
because it's right at the cell tissue
interface it's not one structure it's a
set of structures or an ensemble of
structures that I'll come to in a minute
so it is a challenging problem but
nonetheless an exciting one from the
point of view of how a technologist or
an engineer will look at so I just would
like to very quickly introduce the the
two sort of families at a higher level
the branch sugars they're very bad
complex structures with the core with
several radiating chains virtually all
therapeutic proteins about 80 to 90
percent of them have sugars attached to
them several proteins in our body the by
and large the reason is that you can do
this as the most extensive post
translation modification that protein
undergoes and in many ways they perform
the function of recognition how two
proteins can interact the way the sugars
regulate that the way the proteins fold
the way you target proteins how does an
e PO know once it's made in the bone
marrow to go to the brain or how do
proteins know where they need to go what
kinds of information are there there's a
lot of information that's coded in the
glycans that tell them how they get
targeted a very important part when you
move away from a cell and look at in the
context of an organism is the half-life
how long is the blood is a drug in the
blood how long is the particular protein
in the blood the half-life that life of
these molecules are very dramatically
regulated by the sugars that are
attached to them and obviously so on and
so forth in terms of stability and
specificity so I'd like to very quickly
introduce using this schema the other
family of sugars which are the linear
sugars these are the sugars that
virtually code every eukaryotic human
cell and here's a schema for cell these
ant like structures are the proteins to
which the sugar chains radiate our own
president has worked on some of these
proteins in the nervous system in terms
of how the neurons grow these are
fundamental protein molecules as I said
that regulate how extracellular
molecules are signaling molecules bind
to cognate receptors on the cell surface
so that they get the necessary
information in terms of well what
happens so in many ways you could view
them as they're found of the cell ECM
inter
they act as a reservoir to store
sequester and present several of these
signaling molecules of the cell so that
the cells know what to do and also when
you zoom in do these ant like structures
here are the preferred chains that are
attached they modulate the signaling
molecules in a very specific way in
other words you can have these long
chains to which proteins attached and
that's presented to a surface receptor
on the cell to initiate signals or not
and what's fascinating is a point that
I've come back to is several pathogens
viruses bacteria protozoans use these
glycans on the cell surface in our
bodies as a way to infect and achieve
these tropism how a flu virus infects in
a very specific way it affects the upper
Airways as against hepatitis which
affects the liver cells for instance so
I'll touch upon that briefly but this is
sort of a high-level introduction to how
the linear sugars look like and if you
actually zoom in the way it's able to
perform this diverse functions in terms
of regulating how a signaling molecule
binds to these sugars to be presented to
a cognate receptor is the fact that
there's numerous sequences that are
possible for an example when you have
four bases that make DNA in 20 amino
acids that make proteins
there are about 48 different building
blocks that gets made in a linear
fashion to give you this complexity
therefore you can get the diversity that
you need to bind to a whole host of
proteins to mediate the signaling
processes so what I'm going to do is to
through an example give you the idea of
when you look at these structures I said
there are these ensembles of structures
that are present how do you look at this
problem and how do you demystify the
sugar structure sequence to the function
and I'd like to use one specific example
that's relevant that's that's going to
be relevant but then I'll go through a
variety of applications so with regard
to the technologies to understand how
sugars look if you will on the surface
of a protein or a cell first you need to
understand what does ensembl means and
how do you go about doing that and
there's one particularly very relevant
practical problem that basically frames
this question which is several biotech
drugs I mean after the sort of the small
molecule pharmaceutical drugs
as the sat statins which are about lemon
angstroms in size several of the protein
based drugs like area through
appointment
insulin human growth hormone and so on
which have been a product of the biotech
revolutions are pretty complex proteins
but what's fascinating is that when you
look at the top ten proteins that are
used taraf Utica Li in the clinic nine
of the ten are glycosylated proteins so
the sugars on these molecules
dramatically influence the biological
properties of these and it's expected
that these protein based therapeutics
are going to be the mainstay of the sort
of in sort of the pharmaceutical biotech
kinds of drugs that are going to come
out so to name a few such as Epogen and
factor eight and so on and part of the
challenge that we took on was to try to
understand how do we take this to the
next level we looked at the proteins now
these glycoproteins on sugars and how do
they affect the biological functions of
these molecules and I just want to put
it in the context of the story that I
made said earlier is that troopers have
been around and historically people have
viewed it as something that should say
Salta deal with get rid of it in fact
one of the reasons that I stayed on here
at MIT actually graduated from the
Harvard MIT division of Health Sciences
and technology program with the energy
level that was there at MIT Iowa spend I
was basically told not to work in this
area they said this is carbohydrates
this is the last thing you want to touch
it's the most difficult things to do but
a point that I'll come back to I drew
upon the energy that was in this
environment actually played tennis with
the chemical engineer and it's sort of
the fusion of the biology and
engineering in terms of the way we're
thinking about the problem that enabled
us to tackle up out of sequence sugars
in a way that people were able to
sequence DNA in proteins so that we
could really open the Pandora's box if
you will and try and understand what
sugars do so with proteins of the
mindset that people had when I started
working in this area is forget it just
get rid of it it's not important because
it's useless but now we know that
they're not impurities they affect
several important properties
particularly the way these drugs behave
so the question to me then was this is
very fascinating
look at the system how do you look at
this ensemble of structures because it
is the poly dispersed heterogeneous
ensemble of structures that we need to
visualize we can visualize DNA we can
visualize proteins but how do you look
at the sugar code on a protein or in a
cell to really understand what's going
on and I'd like to use this sort of
analogy to illustrate the idea in many
ways looking at sugars on a protein or
on a cell it's like looking at image
processing it's looking at how do you
look at an image and to me these the
analogy that I've used is sort of the
six blind men and the elephant everybody
was trying to figure out what this was
each person got it wrong but the idea
was you really need to understand what
that whole picture looked like and here
is the elephant so what we did was we
brought me several different orthogonal
analytical techniques each technique had
its strengths but there are limitations
or weaknesses that in terms of studying
sugar because you're looking as I said
as an ensemble or a set of structures
then we make measurements associated
with these then if you do not link these
measurements in a meaningful way and I
love this to just slapping on raw data
during image processing if the data
doesn't talk to each other you get a
blurry picture the more you're able to
integrate the various measurements
you're able to then get this entire
picture this is sort of a concept behind
it what would we really do is we took a
variety of different analytical
techniques mass spectrometry NMR and
different kinds of other analytical
techniques exploited the strengths of
these techniques understood the
limitations and weaknesses of those in
such a fashion that we then developed a
number based approach to code
information associated at the various
building blocks why is this important
the point that I made earlier I really
needed an electrical engineer a chemical
engineer a biologist a carbohydrate
chemist as a team to really take on this
problem in a very interdisciplinary
fashion and what we were then able to do
is you know solve this as a puzzle where
we were able to look at not just one
structure but a set of structures that
existed either on a protein or in a cell
and we were able to build build
beyond that and once we got the the
sugar structures we have actually linked
to to a sort of the genome and the
proteome database so what we're now able
to do at the example that I used earlier
about Ipoh here's the Ipoh molecule with
the for sugar sites in it and I said
earlier that the effect folding the
effect the way you look at the half-life
of it what's also interesting is if you
let these cells group which re
commenting Ipoh the human cells that
make even process condition dramatically
affect the kinds of sugars that the Ipoh
molecules display on their surface so
part of our approach is to take a very
integrated way of understanding what are
the different sugars are attached to
what sites of these proteins how much
are they present is that is their
abundance and their location so you can
begin to see one Apryl molecule now has
been translated into these 150 different
unique structures with the sugars that
are attached and what they do so the
next question obviously is going to be
once you have this information what are
you going to do how do you understand
the biology now we'll come back to that
in a minute
so this is giving you a flavor with
regard to how we did this the branch
sugars then we also took on the problem
of trying to demystify existing sugar
drugs in the market one that you might
know heparin and low molecular weight
heparin it's the drug of choice
as an anticoagulant especially for
things like deep vein thrombosis which
is DVT but you want to make sure that
you don't clot but what's also
interesting is this is the drug that's
used as sort of the mainstay for anybody
who goes into the hospital with a chest
pain anything to do with acute coronary
syndrome in terms of ACS but what's
fascinating is that this drug though
it's been around for the last eighty
five years
it's the gimmick essentially it's a
complex mixture that's been so poorly
characterized it's sort of Li it's like
it's the analogy it's like what was the
case with insulin in the early 30s when
insulin was isolated from the from the
pancreatic you know organ from a pig
it was always used as as a mixture then
people saw this beneficial effect and it
was a sort of a serendipitous discovery
the story with heparin and low molecular
ate heparins is no different and what's
fascinating is I flew we approached this
problem in using the technologies we
said
it was still viewed as this complex
mixture it had these very interesting
set of biological activities but the
fact remained that this is you know a
big product in the pharmaceutical
industry with the poor understanding the
FDA really did not know how to look at
the system and how to really understand
the complex set of structures
correlating to its function and again to
put it into context here's a small
molecule drug like your statins or your
cox-2 inhibitors and so on just to put
it in context here is your heparin
Sonoma like the way it happens there
thousands of chains with many many
structures and sequences that really
pose this challenge in terms of how you
understand that so part of what we did
was sort of the proof of the pudding was
in the inking in the sense of could we
take the technology that we develop do
the so-called image processing and try
to be able to give you a picture of what
this complex mixture looked like
therefore you can begin to understand
how these structures correlate to
functions so what I'm now going to do is
change gears and walk you through some
applications we took these set of
different technologies we develop I'm
going to walk you through a hand full of
very specific examples of what we did
and to put it in context with regard to
why sugars are important going beyond
the energy molecule that is that I
talked about so one interesting thing we
found was once we could start sequencing
these sugars we could understand what
was going on with regard to the sugar
structures is that tumor cells on their
surface contains sugar sequences that
either kept the shirt
the tumors dormant so that they were not
rapidly dividing the point that I'd made
earlier that how they respond to the
environment with regard to signaling or
they could display sugar structures that
actually enhance that ability to respond
to growth signals and they'd rapidly
start dividing and it was in balance so
the red sugar sequences kept these cells
quiet and would not permit signals to go
into the cells but the blue sequences
could activate signals and enable these
tumor cells to rapidly divide and this
balance was critical and then what
happens is that during the process of
tumor progression you
get more of the green stuff growing
going on these cells so that they can
more rapidly respond to these signaling
molecules and take off in terms of their
growth so part of what we then began
doing is once we began to understand the
biology behind it we began generating
various of these sugar fragments to try
to really understand could we then take
these red guys give them we understand
them in terms of mechanisms not really
the cellular level but in terms of
animal models and we have generated
various different kinds of sugar
compounds and a lot of the studies one
of them which is actually plant arrived
that I talked about Brian's use being
very excited to support and the other
ones are in the general heparin families
and they're going under phase one kind
of testing right now the fact that
sugars change on these cells and begs
the question could this be a marker for
distinct states that a particular cell
type isn't so here's a set of healthy
cells but then as you progress towards
the disease in this case it's cancer we
now know a simple example I can give you
is PSA for prostate cancer we all know
that it's a very controversial thing
just looking at the protein levels of
PSA doesn't really tell you what stage
you're you are in in this cancer
progression what we found at B in others
did was the fact that the sugars on PSA
actually subtly change and give you a
better handle or a signature to the
distinct state that you are in
during the progression of prostate
cancer so what we're now doing is we're
dealing with several human samples to
really try to translate what we found in
the lab there's something clinically
meaningful in the sort of a whole
diagnostic platform that's being
developed to really sort of harness or
leverage and understand good sugars be a
better market because there are enough
you know evidence is to support that the
sugar structures change much more subtly
than sort of this analogue regulation of
function that I talked about earlier one
of the fascinating things is the point
that I made earlier about how pathogens
infect so if you look at epithelial
cells these are the cell lines that line
our upper Airways our gut the
blood-brain barrier these are the
cells that are exposed to the outside
and the way the body sees the outside
and here's a typical epithelial cell
it's polarized it has a head in the tail
very simply it's an apical site at a
base or lateral side and here's the
blood vessel normally molecules are
transported across in an active way
there's a receptor that binds and that
things are you know transported through
what's called as a trans cellular
transport what's fascinating is that
several normal biological processes
exploit what's called as a para cellular
transport between cells there are these
junctions that hold these cells together
and then solutes and proteins and others
from this side go in to the other side
and there's a way that there's a
gatekeeping mechanism going on what we
found is the fact that the the apical
glycans in very specific way regulate
whether these junctions open or shut and
therefore what goes in or what does it
in many ways the the analogy is like the
Ali Baba and the Forty Thieves you need
the right card to swipe and if you do
that you have access in and what's even
fascinating is the fact that these black
hands can be used as ways to open and to
close these junctions but pathogens
several of these not only bind to these
glycans but use it as a way to mimic the
system and and open these junctions as a
way to get into the system if you will
so we're beginning to see several
bacterial and virus species actually use
the sugars on these cell surface as a
way to get entry into distinct cellular
compartments and you can begin to see
that then you have these glycans which
are different for the upper Airways and
the blood-brain barrier and the low gut
the kinds of sugars that are there in
these cells uniquely regulate what gets
accessed in there not and and and how
the access is regulated this is a pretty
exciting area so the point that I made
earlier that when you have these sugars
that regulate proteins on the outside
they store them they release them the
kinetics become important what we began
to do is to address the issue of
combination therapy we said you know
when you look at a cell here's a tumor
cell there's the blood vessels at around
them the endothelial cells grows in one
way the tumor cells grow in one this the
sugars are different the way they
regulate these compartment is different
so if you really want to
Stan what's going on as tumors growth
with regard to the blood vessels then
you need to understand how these two
compartments relate to each other and if
you take off-the-shelf drugs off to the
shelf chemotherapy drugs off the shelf
sort of engine anti-angiogenesis drug
and so just combining them the standard
way of mixing a and B together part of
our thinking was if there is a very
important component of how these sugar
molecules regulate the entire micro
environment in very distinct ways then
drugs need to be delivered or drugs act
in similar ways to cut a long story
short what we then decided to do was
took off-the-shelf drugs and decided to
develop two compartments we call this
delivery device a nano cell there's an
inner core an outer core the inner core
has the chemo therapeutic drug the outer
core has the anti-angiogenesis drug in
many ways sort of like a smart bomb
approach where you want to put the chemo
therapeutic agent inside so that it
doesn't escape and the anti-angiogenesis
and the most important thing is the fact
that you need to regulate the kinetics
of the release of these two compartments
in distinct ways which reflect back
again the way these cells grow in terms
of how the tumor cells grow and the
endothelial cells grow so putting a long
story short and I don't want to sort of
give you too much of sort of data dump
here but what we found is when we come
when he looked at the ability for these
tumors to grow in animals and the number
of days here and explore compared with
not only the controls but the various
just physically mixed combination
therapy you know it's like taking just a
chemotherapy and anti-angiogenesis as
two different regiments but then doing
it in this controlled release fashion so
that you're affecting the kinetics
really what we found with some great
dramatic effects in terms of the
survival outcomes this is the the normal
so the controls drop dead in 20 days the
the combination the standard current
combination therapies of taking combined
effects you know give you a little bit
extra survival but a strategy where
you're beginning to look at the spatial
temporal release kinetics in the way
cells come together to form tissues and
organs and how these black hands
conceptually play a role you can then
begin to really not only tease apart the
system in a you know in an integrated
way but you could leverage it in terms
of these kinds of drug delivery
strategies
and we're basically taking this is
trying to figure out how we can use
combination therapy in the area of
treating stroke in the interest of time
I'm not going to go through that but
what I wanted to show you is the fact
that we are really leveraging this to
the extent that we possibly can in terms
of novel approaches to you know
treatment of diseases the last point
that I want to quickly touch upon is how
this field has integrated itself to the
genomics and proteomics area as I said
since glycans are very important we now
have a large high throughput data in the
area of glycomics MIT is one of the
Centers for an international effort for
consortium it's called Consortium for
functional glycomics
where we basically house the largest
data sets that's there this field we
have all the different like hand
structures we go all the way from the
molecule to the mouse of a molecule to
the human and correlate the link between
the genome proteome into glycome
and generate different kinds of data
whether it's data from the cells to the
target organ systems and then our goal
was to really be able to use relational
databases and use a simple
porca like a molecule page that truly
integrates these diverse kinds of
information so I think this field this
is emerging to be an important one where
it has had its challenges from the
molecular evolution the genomic
revolution has been possible because of
the technology and the way that we have
looked at this the more systems fashion
but it has begun to address some of the
several complex and challenging issues
that we've had to summary it's an
emerging field fundamental tools and by
a large roles in biological processes be
limited by several tools that were
really needed to kinds of branched inch
and the linear complex and information
dense and we've developed several
different tools to address at the end of
the day how structure correlated
activity and function with many
different expecting applications and
last but not the least funding from NIH
and this is my group several different
members of my group we're obviously
responsible for this but I need to touch
upon
some of the collaborators that we have
had and the question of soul wad could
we really take this and go beyond what
we were able to do was really leverage
there's different technologies that were
developed at MIT and take on looking at
these glycoproteins and low molecular
weight heparin and a company has been
spun off that has really taken this
problem and in terms of kind of really
translated into the real world thank you
very much
I think I think you guys can see why we
had so much fun putting this this panel
together I'm running out of adjectives
holy cats something like that this is
not science fiction this is just
hardcore science and engineering taking
place right here I'd like to introduce
to you Martha Gray Martha is the
director of the HST program the health
science and technology program at Joint
Alliance has existed for the last 35
years between Harvard and MIT in that
role as director she is part of and
helped guiding some the marvelous
research that's taking place there to
take much of what we've we've seen here
today
and to help translate that into medical
practice so Martha
he's just fiddling with my mic is it can
you hear me sound all right so this is
most likely what George's coronary
artery looked like when he was admitted
to the hospital and when you consider
that where that dotted line is is where
the edge of the artery normally should
be I think you can appreciate that this
extra tissue inside there most likely
caused a reduction in the amount of
blood that could flow through that
artery I can figure out how to turn this
on and and that was the ultimate cause
of his symptoms now what I remember most
about George is not what his disease
coronary artery look like and it's not
even that both his father and his elder
brother died of sudden cardiac death
what I remember is this big almost jolly
guy with a very deep booming voice who
was willing excited even to be a guinea
pig for me while I was learning to do a
history and physical now I remember that
history and physical so well it took me
more than two hours I'd like to think
it's not because I was new and slow but
because he was so busy asking me
questions but I met him when I was doing
my clinical experience at Mount Auburn
Hospital while I was a graduate student
at MIT I went to see George the day he
left the hospital and he handed me a
card with his address on it and said you
need to let me know what happens over
the years he was very taken with the
idea of putting engineers in a clinical
setting having them have hands-on
experience in medicine and he thought
that you techies you guys at MIT will
figure out what to do for guys with
hearts like his now I'm embarrassed to
say I have no idea where that card is
now and it's also the case that I
haven't done anything directly to help
guys with hearts like his but many of
our faculty and students have and I
wanted to share some of those stories
with you as well as some other stories
and I'll dedicate these to George and
finding where he was he could come this
would be the card so
the therapeutic concept in his case is
really conceptually straightforward you
removed the blockage and the blood flows
now in practice it doesn't work like
that
and I got to figure out how to use this
pointer somebody help me well I'm sure
there's a button here somewhere ah here
it is my day of sitting here I found it
the nerves get you everywhere okay so
you probably have the idea by now
there's a catheter to thread up through
the goring to the heart and in the
region of the lesion or of the blockage
which you can see there in yellow a
balloon is expanded and in this
particular instance there's a metal
casing a wire mesh around that balloon
it's called a stent and that holds the
vessel open in georgia's era actually
was before the days of these stents and
it was in the early days of what's
called balloon angioplasty we're just
the balloon was put in place though
sometimes there was the problem of it
reeked elapsing on itself now the good
news is that this rhoda rooder approach
works pretty well initially because of
that collapse the balloon would fail you
know under 10% of the time with stents
it's really relatively rare the bad news
is in about 1 to 6 months these things
both fail you and what by failure here
mean needs another angioplasty or needs
coronary artery bypass graft so some of
the work I'm going to describe his work
of Professor Eleazar Edelman who is an
alum and he focused on why is it that
those vessels become blocked again after
they're opened and can the procedure and
the devices be improved now if you look
at a vessel after this six-month period
this is one such example this is the
edge of the artery these little black
marks in this example or where the stent
was and you can see there's this massive
regrowth into the lumen and that again
blocks blocks blood vessels the thinking
at the time was this response was really
due to the fact you've taken this
diseased artery blown it open
all kinds of biological things happen
and that's it he said well that's
probably all true but what about the
stent itself and could that play a role
in why these things fail so these are
the first generation stents and
so-called slotted tube or that's his
name for them and if you put those in an
artery and look at the lining of the
vessel 60% of the cells that line that
vessel were scraped off if you will
nuded from the vessel wall so that can't
be good and the possible reasons for
them that are things like this stent is
it expanded the way it was constructed
it would shorten and you can see it
buckles a bit here and also there's
balloon contact with the vessel vessel
wall and any of those and perhaps more
things could cause the the induced the
biological response that that led to
restenosis fast-forward some years with
some new designs that were developed
based on some data I won't show you the
corrugated ring design differs and that
there is no shortening no buckling or at
least not measurable buckling and much
much less balloon contact though it has
exactly the same amount of wire now the
biological measures are sort of the what
you need to look at and if you compare
if he compared the slotted tent a tube
to the corrugated ring on every measure
and these are four of them there was a
market improvement with the corrugated
ring like the denudation the clotting
and so forth these were the first data
to show that the stent design itself
nevermind the disease and everything
else a stent design itself played an
important role in the response to this
therapy it also changed the intellectual
property or commercial landscape because
knowing that the stent design mattered
gave companies a different axis with
which to compete now you've probably
heard recently and hopefully not
experienced directly drug eluting stents
and there the concept is well one
another way in which you could prevent
this regrowth is to put a drug on the
stent use a drug that prevents the
proliferation of those
that grow in and looking at some
clinical data people have tried this now
for a number of drugs and without naming
the drugs if you look at clinical data
and compare the restenosis rate relative
to a Bair stent you can see that some
drugs work and some don't
the thought is well this is the
difference in biological activity it's
the difference in what happens in in
clearance in the bloodstream and so
forth these three drugs are equally
effective in vitro in that in the test
tube if you will improve preventing
proliferation again now is our challenge
the paradigm said well that might be
true but we should look at really where
does that drug go what's it interacting
with and maybe we can get some insight
into how to best both build these things
and tell a priori whether these devices
will work and so this is one example of
one drug that's fluorescently labeled
and you can see at this time point that
that the drug is very close to where the
stent is and I'm not showing you can
also look in the depths of the tissue
and it turns out if you look at all this
data and again I'm collapsing many years
that there's a good correspondence
between the properties of the drug and
it's interaction with extracellular
matrix that stuff that ron was talking
about and the transport of that drug
into the depth of the tissue that
corresponds very well with a clinical
outcome so over the past 20 years 30
years since George there's been a
dramatic improvement in in therapies
that really came about from challenging
the paradigm and understanding the
tissue device and drug interaction
that's restoring blood flow another in
the sort of realm of treating cardiac
problems another basic therapeutic
concept is maintaining electrical
signaling or restoring electrical
signaling and one sort of exemplar of
this issue is the problem of sudden
cardiac death out of every seven if you
one will die of sudden cardiac death
that's more than will die of cancer and
the cause of that death is arrhythmia in
the ventricles you might have underlying
cardiac disease but what kills you is
the the
meeow that prevents the heart from
beating properly there is a treatment
that's extraordinarily effective an
implantable defibrillator the problem is
who do you give the defibrillator to if
you gave it to everybody who had cardiac
risk only four percent or so would
actually need it and that's a very
invasive therapy for that kind of
population and I should say that the is
as the slide says the sometimes the
first indication of cardiac disease is
sudden death and obviously it's too late
by then so I'm sharing a little bit of
the work of Professor Richard Cohen
who's been thinking about this issue in
various dimensions for several decades
he's also an alum of MIT and he's looked
at stochastic behavior of heart muscle
and experimental models and has really
focused on strategies for predicting the
risk of arrhythmia now what you can
actually measure at the surface of the
body as an electrocardiogram and what
that's detecting is a whole collection
of a whole bunch of small currents
within the heart muscle itself and if
you were to be able to visualize current
in a working muscle if there's a very
coordinated pattern that allows this
heart to beat effectively and the
question is can you extract from this
information something that tells you
there's a little blip over here and the
answer is you can I wouldn't show the
example if it weren't that true
and at a microvolt level at a level that
you can't even see here it turns out
that there's something called T wave
alternans that can show up a micro volt
change if your heart rate is reasonably
high and this has been tested in a
number of clinical trials and this is
one and in this group of patient those
that had a negative T wave alternans
test in the 18 months had no significant
cardiac event whereas a quarter of those
with a positive test had a significant
cardiac event and this is the only
statistically significant risk
predictor of of of a risk of sudden
cardiac death and this is this
technology has been commercialized to by
MIT to a company called Cambridge heart
it's been recently approved for Medicare
funding and I would point out that this
is sort of one early example of the idea
of being able to predict who you should
treat when the population is very large
it's the personalized medicine problem
how do you know how to give a very
effective treatment which people should
receive it the third fundamental
therapeutic concept if you if blood flow
isn't the problem or electrical isn't
the problem or you can't do anything
about it restoring muscle function and
that's the third example I want to give
and it's work of Gordana banyak
Novakovich and lisa freed and they're in
the tissue engineering area and a
focused on principle design of tissue
engineering along the lines that linda
was talking about earlier and here's the
met the conceptual concept there's an
area of the heart that's damaged and not
functioning properly
could you actually put a patch on there
that's works and restore function that
way and the idea was to take a polymer
seed it within the experiment I'm going
to show you rat heart cells they
penetrate the polymer you let it/them
seed and take hold for a few days and
then put in a dish and stimulated with a
pacemaker actually a real pacemaker and
so that during the time is developing
its contracting in a way that's sort of
analogous to a heart and after eight
days in culture you actually get a
tissue that's beating these are silicon
spacers here is the electrode can't see
the other electrode very well you can
get individual muscle cells they'll
contract spontaneously this is the first
time anybody's been able to put create a
tissue to compete in an organized way
and so this there's millions of cells
cutting across there and if you look at
the ultra structure the engineered
tissue both an electron microscope level
and a light microscope level look very
similar to native tissue
so these have really been transforming
advances in technology improved therapy
for blood flow that came about from
understanding cell tissue interaction
trying to predict a risk for electro
cardiac events and at least as a
potential restoring muscle function and
this was on the MIT website this
February so if I saw George now and I
had his address I'd send him a
Valentine's Day card with this on it and
try to describe what I've just described
to you now what I have worked on if not
the heart but on problems related to our
thright Asst and I've the work I'll
describe for you as work I've done with
another alum professor Burstein
arthritis is according the Arthritis
Foundation the leading cause of
disability in the United States one in
three of you probably have it so very
very common and the treatment is really
one of two things one is pain relief
either by over-the-counter or by
prescription kinds of drugs and then
finally the last resort treatment is
replacing the joint now it's easy to
sort of say off what a crude treatment
but this was invented only in the late
60s and this has kept many many people
out of wheelchairs
now they last about 20 years so this has
been an extraordinarily high-impact
innovation but again as linda noted the
ideal would be to try to prevent this
from happening so you didn't even get to
that stage and there are several new
therapies on the horizon some are
nutraceuticals virtually every drug
company I'm aware of is has a program
and trying to develop arthritis riddick
therapies there's new surgical
strategies coming down the pike and that
have been suggested and used and the
challenges so you've got this thing that
works in an animal or works in a test
tube or petri dish how do you really
know if they work particularly in humans
in the current way you can look at
either development of disease or
progression or if efficacy of a
treatment is x-ray
so this is an x-ray of one of my
students patients knee joints and this
is the thigh bone the femur the tibia
the calf bone and you can see the space
between the joints and if you're used to
looking at x-rays you'd say this space
is - is narrower than usual
now you can't actually see cartilage by
x-ray so the fact that this is narrow
means that the cartilage that would
normally be between the joints must be
missing and in fact this is the knee of
this patient and this yellow stuff
should be covering the whole joint you
can see it's been completely stripped of
its of its cartilage and I think you can
appreciate how insensitive this kind of
approaches magnetic resonance imaging
has been a dramatic improvement in first
in the first instance because you can
actually now see the cartilage tissue
you're not just looking at space between
bone and what's been emerging is
actually molecular imaging of cartilage
looking at as I'll describe briefly in a
second protocol a sugar x' that are it
really am functionally very important
inside the cartilage and it gives you
information that you can't visualize on
an anatomic measure and so if you can
actually see very early stage changes
then you have the potential to ask
questions like does the treatment work
who gets away how fast does it happen
and so forth and I wanted to give an
example one example autologous
chondrocyte transplantation popularized
in this country by Genzyme and the idea
is that if you have a local defect in
your cartilage you go in surgically
clean it out remove it fill it with
cartilage cells and then cover it with a
piece of tissue now how do you know if
this idea works what did genzyme have to
do for the FDA well they had to ask
subjects to agree to a second what's
called a second look biopsy second look
arthroscopy which means they make an
incision in your knee joint put a light
tube in and actually put a device in and
remove a small piece of your your
cartilage then they stain it
histological you've taken out of the
body you slice it very thin six microns
then
you stain it in this purple color the
more darker the purple the better the
cartilage this is much bigger than a
biopsy it would be much smaller
here's bone here's cartilage the biopsy
wouldn't go down to the bone normally it
would just be a small piece here this
has at least two problems one is if
you're doing well as a patient
the last thing you want to somebody to
go in and take a piece of cartilage out
that you've just tried to fix and the
second thing is is the sampling problem
where it's let's say this were it where
exactly do you sample and how do you
interpret that single sample from
something that's a very heterogeneous
piece so it has all kinds of problems
but that's the best that it had been
available and what we can do now for the
very first time is take not using the
same example using imaging you can
actually get a surrogate for this this
histology where the blue darker blue is
like dark blue here and light purple
turns red on this in this diagram you
can see there's good correspondence
between this yet this did not require
that you take it and slice it into six
micron thick sections this is a you know
this block is a few centimeters by a few
centimeters and this is a thin imaging
and Mar slice so you can do this in
vitro it turns out you can also do this
in vivo and this is one of the first
images showing that you can make these
measurements in vivo this is from
somebody who had the autologous
chondrocyte transplantation in this
region of the tissue and two months
after she had had that operation you can
see that there's tissue there but it's
colored red and here's the scale red
means there's not much of that important
molecule yellow and blue means there's
more and so this region is filled but
presumably not functional yet and the
x-ray and the M are other M ours for
this you could not distinguish those
patterns for a different patient one and
a half years after the operation this
was the region of her transplant and you
can't distinguish the transplant region
from the rest of the tissue now this
isn't to say that autologous chondrocyte
transplantation works the study wasn't
designed to in a randomized way to
follow people over time that's ongoing
but what it does say is that this
measurement is actually sensitive to the
kinds of changes
you'd want to be able to detect and a
number of drug companies have now begun
to adopt this for their arthritis
clinical trials and a number of groups
have begun to adopt it to begin to ask
some of the more fundamental physiology
and biology questions like who gets
arthritis how does it develop and I
wanted to share one of those with you
from Leif dahlberg's group in Sweden who
adopted this technique about six years
ago and he looked at subjects who had
complaints of knee pain but had normal
x-rays normal in every other regard so
each of these bars is a think of them as
a person and they're just ranked
according to the molecular index to that
color that I was showing you and you can
see there's a broad distribution it's
now six years later and he's gone back
to them and they've had repeat x-rays
and seven of them actually have evidence
on the x-ray of osteoarthritis of and
one of them has already had a total
joint replacement and they tend to be
bunched towards the low end so this is
early indication that this may be have
some predictive value about what what
might happen in arthritis so one of the
things that was you know eye opening if
you will about the imaging things I just
showed you it just allows you to see
things you couldn't see before which
allows you to ask questions you couldn't
ask before and I wanted to highlight one
last set of stories the Avenue lay
Martino Center for biomedical imaging
that was established in about five years
ago in 1999 and their work in brain
imaging and Bruce Rosen is the director
of the Center Greg Sorensen the
associate director and George Bush is
one of the faculty there now about 20
years ago if you were to look at 25
years ago brain images again this is
this was transformative in its time you
could see the outline of the brain this
is a cross-section taken if you will
that way you can sort of get a sense of
structures but I'm sure you can
immediately discern how much more detail
in the kinds of images that we can get
today
and just from that kind of images and
the kinds of Technology computational
technologies around a sequence of images
taken through the brain you can get a
three-dimensional representation and
what our pioneering advances you can
take this very convoluted structure blow
it up sort of like a raisin turning into
a grape and begin to see what anatomic
structures might be next to one another
and again so you can begin to ask
physiological questions or where do the
different pathways in the brain go and
I'm not going to talk about any use of
these for any medical application or
neuroscience application but I think you
can appreciate the the kinds of
questions you could ask that you simply
couldn't ask before that was focusing on
measuring structures in anatomy what
you'd really love to be able to do in
addition is to be able to tell where the
brain is activated and this is one of
the pioneering images of called
functional magnetic resonance imaging
that Bruce Rosen was one of the first
inventors of and this little dot here
shows that there's a difference after a
particular task in blood oxygenation and
blood oxygenation is used as a surrogate
for electrical function so presumably
and you think you use an energy source
and it reduces the amount of oxygen in
the blood that's the concept so I want
to show you how an F functional magnetic
resonance fMRI study is done running an
experiment with you on the next series
of slides you're going to see a word
it's going to be written in a font and
that font is colored and what I want you
to do is yell out as fast as you can and
your time to lunch depends on this as
fast as you can what color the font is
you got it okay
so with practice you get better and I
didn't get you give you a chance to
practice
that's called a strop test and it's one
of the tests that's done in looking at
people with attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder I know my friends
tell me that should be prevalent here I
didn't want to use that joke you
obviously thought of it yourself
so as you can quite obviously from this
picture if you say the rich regions of
the brain light up it's very very
different in in kids with ADHD and so
again we're opening up a whole new Vista
who knows what that means biologically
or diagnostically is early data but it's
you can see how it's just opening up the
door to all kinds of different questions
now I said that measured brain activity
you can do em through measuring blood
oxygenation now brain activity really
happens on a millisecond timescale not
on a second timescale of mr magneto
encephalography is a technique allows
you to measure electrical activity of
the brain the problem is you can't
localize it you can't tell when you
measure it surface of the brain exactly
where it came from
and the folks at the Martino Center said
well what if we combine the best of both
worlds use the MRI to constrain the
inverse problem and then if you will
make a movie of activation and this is
one example of that again in this case
they're reading novel words and when you
see the thing restart you'll see it
starts at the posterior of the brain and
it moves itself up to the frontal lobe
back and forth so you can see this
fleeting thought is very complicated in
terms of going back to front to back to
front and it gives you a whole new
appreciation for the complexities of
what systems neuroscience is likely to
mean when
think about what does it mean to read a
word and remember it so I've given you a
number of vignettes you know heart mine
arthritis and of of things that have
really over the past 20 years gone if
you will from bench to bedside
they've all been things that I think
every single person that list has gotten
a grant proposal back saying it's
impossible it will never work and I've
showed you that these things in fact
have worked and had had tremendous
impact the and each of them these
advances was enabled by a true advance
in technology another important sort of
common theme is though I told you the
sort of head investigator in fact if you
were to go into any of their
laboratories or talk to them about the
work though no they won't say oh it was
just my engineering background that did
it actually they had teams of people
within the labs that include physical
scientists and engineers biologists
physicians and so forth so that's the
case for all of the stories I told you
and they really attribute the advances
I've shown you to the ability to create
that integration and the ratcheting that
you get by having the multiple
disciplines talking to one another the
theme you've heard I think throughout
this morning which brings me to Health
Sciences and Technology that a number of
people is mentioned I just wanted to
give you a sense of the landscape in
1970 and sort of to fill out what's here
at MIT now Health Science and Technology
was established in 1970 it's a if you
will a joint department that's owned by
Harvard and MIT it's it's done
interdisciplinary education and research
programs and it really focuses on the
integration the translation from bench
to bedside and of course as everybody at
MIT innovation and we use this to talk
about equal footing of the different
disciplines and really integrating the
different professions so we can move
both identify the critical unmet medical
NEADS and bring them bring the solutions
to the bedside and industry is an
important player in all of that we've
just passed a thousand alums and we have
450 students enrolled including PhD
students MD students MS MBA students and
so forth and we have 50 primary and
joint faculty like Doug the mentioned in
the biological engineering this group
has grown in recent years I put this up
here to say I've selected a very small
set of what's happening here I said ok
well for tech they wanted I picked the
alums who are faculty who are doing
something that's already reached the
clinic ok so that means that I haven't
been able to talk to you about the
genomics or the viola informatics or the
stuff that's dealing with predicting
outcome in space through our active
active work with NASA about quantum dots
to do to bring molecules target
molecules for cancer and on and on so
hopefully this will intrigue you and you
can come visit us sometime Doug Doug
talked about the map and I think one of
the things HST does is bring under the
MIT umbrella the hospitals and Harvard
Medical School so that the landscape for
bio and medical engineering at MIT
actually brings in the local very Brent
teaching hospitals in medical school and
industry which leads me to my closing
point which is we are extraordinarily
well positioned I think at MIT to have
just a huge impact over the next decades
and advancing human health around the
world and when you think about the
number of disciplines such as biological
engineering that starting in the fall
through biology which has been here for
a long time the number of centers that
have formed plus the fact that with HST
we've sort of got Harvard sort of under
the same umbrella there is no other
institution that I'm aware of in the
world that has the strength
the collection that we have here here at
MIT so we're delighted that that Susan's
excited about this as a as an area and I
think we hopefully come back in 35 years
for the next tech day and have equally
transformative advances thank you okay
yeah I think we're gonna still have some
questions but a little bit abbreviated
time so a professor Hawk field and and
professors if you can join up here on
stage there are two microphones in the
aisles folks downstairs and little
Kresge you'll need to come up we'll try
to get up holidays we don't have the
full half hour if we can line up
questions at those microphones and we'll
get our faculty ready to go one thing
well while we're getting set here
hopefully all of you collected blank
surveys as you came in the door if you
would be so kind to complete those
surveys and leave them as as you exit
they're very important for the tech day
committee that's if you've enjoyed
what's happened here today
very much so it's a result of feedback
that we've gotten on those surveys so
please please in fact do do take the
moment to complete those it's very
helpful to us
and thanks to for all the patience as we
we run a little bit over we'll get you
to lunch in time we promise they told me
that nobody's going to eat the food
until we get there okay yes I think
we're good thank you
since sugars have such an important
influence on operation of the body what
sort of risks are you taking when you
eat a bar of candy two unrelated events
but I think we're trying to really get
to the heart of how what sugar we take
eventually is used in the synthesis of
these more complex sugars but I think
the short answer is I think you
shouldn't worry about it except your
diet hi um with the brain imaging and
all what impact does that have on mental
health like schizophrenia
all right Angela's so there are a number
of emerging analysis techniques the
schizophrenia is an extraordinarily
difficult problem there does look like
there's some anatomic differences that
you can see between schizophrenics and
non schizophrenic
I'm not aware of yet anything that's
showing the kind of functional
differences though I there are groups
looking at that but if you're interested
offline I could give you the names of
some people to talk to yeah I'm like am
I on okay what can you hear me yes
terrific
many of you have seen the new building
going up just across the street from the
new Stata Center the brain and cognitive
science project which is going to be the
new home for all of our neuro scientists
there is tremendous interest among the
neuro scientists to make the kinds of
connections that we believe can be made
almost nowhere except at MIT between the
basic biology the great engineering and
the implications for not just
neurological disease but also
psychiatric disease so a lot of people
interested in it working with the
Martino's Center we really think we're
gonna be able to open up this area ways
that have never could open up the floor
I used to do cardiac tissue culture and
you showed something that I thought was
impossible
you showed cells that had differentiated
into mature cardiac myocytes where
they're myofilaments all lined up
parallel from cell to cell and they seem
to have grown that way in vitro how did
you do that was that just the electrical
stimulation or did you add some magic
growth factors well first of all I want
to make it clear that I didn't do it
Lisa free2go Donovan yak Nabokov it's it
did that but I can't speak to the any
magic formulation growth factors but
they explored in some empirical way in
some strategic ways what population of
cells it turns out just using Maya sites
alone didn't work very well you had to
have a
spectrum of myocytes and that they had
to wait three days before stimulating
otherwise the stimulation itself would
prevent the right connections from
happening between the different cell
that you need to create that kind of
organized structure that you see I don't
know how many days out what what it
would look like if you had looked after
two days of stimulation versus the eight
days that I showed you but I believe
they explored that and they also looked
at the kind of stimulation they were
doing not an exhaustive search but they
were wanted to find something that would
work that you could imagine could work
in vivo so using that's one of the
reasons they used a pacemaker you talked
about autologous chondrocyte transplants
for putting cartilage in knees is canet
also be used for cartilage in vertebrae
for people with back problems no
probably not at this point in in back
problem there's a number of issues and
if you're referring to disc disease
there are people that have artificial
discs that are I don't know if
anything's been FDA approved but it is
FDA approved so Linda may have have more
information no I just read The Wall
Street Journal and remembers but the the
problem with using that technique and
putting it between a load-bearing joint
like you might have there is is you
usually you in the distant you'd have to
remove most of the discs in this case
they take advantage of fact that most of
the cartilage is there and replace the
defect but the properties of that defect
could never support your body weight and
so trying to imagine a little hole in a
disk is not really the way the disc
degenerates okay thank you
you know we saw that you know this
looking at things from the engineering
perspective all of a sudden we start
realizing wait a minute we need to do
glycomics and as I understand it if we
start at the cell level than the
glycomics are sort of getting immediate
interconnection between the cells but
then there's still quite a distance
between there even to the organ level
and I'm wondering is there something
similar that appears to be interesting
as a possible additional discipline
that's like just above the level of
glycomics at the next level of
interconnection about that
I can't imagine another discipline there
because to form a new engineering
discipline you have to have I think a
new science quite honestly and I think
what you're talking about with that is
just a an extension of the sciences as
the things Rama was working on integrate
things from the molecular cell level and
are able to then explain what happens
when they come together and operate as a
tissue so I think it's a natural
extension of our discipline based on the
molecular and cellular sciences dr.
Griffith and dr. Belcher both talked a
lot about structure creating function
and how to really create something new
I'd like to have you just have a chance
to expand having heard some of the more
practical things of the second half
where you think some of the future
design products will actually evolve
into what you think will actually hit
the marketplace to help people
themselves
well I think probably you're directing
that more to Angie but I can save for
what we're doing we have defined some
approaches that would potentially
greatly speed the drug development
process and make it much safer we're in
the process of translating those into
pharmaceutical companies right now and
so we just got interviewed on NPR last
week and they wanted to know the same
thing when it's going to be in the
market not by Christmas so you can't get
this but but we're really trying to get
it in in a research way into some
pharmaceutical company laboratories and
I think this idea of having sort of the
human body on a chip where you have
these things that can screen against how
humans really respond will be trickling
into pharmaceutical research labs over
the next five years and more pervasively
maybe in ten years we have been focusing
that much on medical applications but
more for electronics applications and
the applications that we're most
interested in are are making efficient
solar cells large area solar cells we're
very interested in energy we're
interested in in batteries and different
kinds of alternative energy sources some
of the first things that I have a
company based on this technology they're
looking at or or processing things like
large area displays where you wouldn't
make the whole display biologically but
you would make certain components of it
in a self-assembling way so I think this
technology has the the possibility to
reach many different kinds of
applications we're talking to people
about medical applications as well but
we're really we're interested in
disruptive technology so we're
interested in in trying to figure out
ways that that you may not be able to
make make a material in the other way
how to make inexpensive large-area
self-assembling solar cells and such
question I was just wondering even
though you might be developing this in
one particular area like in health or an
energy I could see it being translated
into clothing where you know you want to
change your outfit you just change the
charge on your clothing and you've got a
whole different display going on or make
it invisible if you wanted to do
something else
we're looking into textiles but mostly
for for army applications but also you
know interesting to have paints that are
reversible paints as well so you could
change the color of your car with with
regard to glycosylation issues that we
had just heard about earlier it does
measured immuno activity where you're
actually just measuring levels of
peptide ever give you a correlation an
exact correlation with bioactivity i
mean if you're really with absolute
peptide levels if you're not necessarily
for example with with in in
endocrinology CSH producing tumours with
relatively low levels of TSH you get a
tremendous stimulation of the thyroid
apparently in association with very low
levels of like oscillation of pirate
rope and so the question is is what's
the purpose of measuring immuno activity
of bio activity is so with that specific
point I think one thing that we've begun
to understand is that by removing
glycosylation you actually affect
protein folding that leads to
immunogenic response one of the
interesting thing is carbohydrate bile
by enlarge generally have not been
immunogenic in the sense you can't
really raise antibodies and things like
that that effectively there's some sort
of a biological mechanism by which
they're selected out yes i want to ask
professor Belcher um in organic and
traditional organic chemistry
same parts tend to work all the time
biological organisms viruses and
bacteria as wastewater treatment plants
and Brewers know are not really very
stable and can reject their you know
diet after a while do you have you know
I wouldn't like to spray an airplane and
then you know wonder did the yeast go
bad today do you have some experience
working with that that's a really good a
good point for the most part with we're
looking at just display and so these are
short peptides that are actually
relative that are actually very stable
that we've shown that like our virus
films and I showed you I carried those
around in my briefcase for about two
years and I could read uh solve it and
it still had greater than ninety
of its function its that was partly
because of of the way itself assembled
itself in a way that that made it just
really really stable so you can you can
store it as a solid but it's an
important point and I think that you
know we've never had any problems with
you know mutations that that no longer
worked anymore but it's something you'd
have to you'd have to test fortunately
it's a relatively easy test and then you
can keep amplifying that back up so we
don't have any data that extends
probably beyond beyond two years but I
think it's an important thing to think
about a political minefield the
intersection of science religion and
politics is of course stem-cell research
which is getting a tremendous play in
the press a lot of interesting things
happening I was wondering what MIT is
doing and thinking along these lines and
in particular beyond that what other
options such as use of somatic stem
cells and growth factors for achieving
some of the same promise what's
happening I'll start with that one
a lot of the work I showed you we use
adult somatic stem cells to achieve
tissue regeneration somatic stem cells
are used every day in the operating room
in the form of marrow and bone
transplants and other things there's an
awful lot of activity at MIT in the area
of stem cells in my lab and several labs
here a lot of us work with adult stem
cells simply because they probably have
the greatest promise to be used for a
lot of things both clinically as well as
technologies like the ones I talked
about tomorrow
there are also faculty who work on
embryonic stem cells and I think a lot
of the effort goes into understanding
how humans develop so embryonic stem
cells in addition to what all gets in
the press are fantastic tools for
understanding developmental biology and
so I I think we have a very pragmatic
approach at MIT as you might imagine
that there is work across the board
we certainly queue to the the
regulations that are imposed by the
government but we also don't issue the
practical implications of a source of
potentially new technologies and new
therapies and I would only add that
there are there's a lot of stem cell
research going on outside of biological
engineering the Whitehead Institute has
a new stem cell initiative we have some
of I think the world leaders say the
world leaders in stem cell biology who
are currently working on our campus and
you know walking this you know narrow
line between federally approved and
federally non-approved lines is tricky
and we are talking about establishing a
place at MIT at the Whitehead where it
would be funded not by federal funds so
that some of this work could go forward
I think as Linda points out if you had a
choice of getting stem cells for your
own therapy that came from someone else
or you know some other work in ism or
cells of your own that had been modified
to do what you want obviously we prefer
to get our own cells because then you
avoid the complications of the immune
response but understanding what a cell
actually has to put in place to be a
toady potent cell is a kind of
understanding that is likely only to
come out of research on embryonic stem
cells so even to realize the full
potential of adult stem cells we're
gonna have to have the better knowledge
of these embryonic stem cells you're
touching on the question I was gonna ask
but put aside stem cell research as a
way of reproducing tissue and organs how
about you know I've been making parts
and maybe many of the my colleagues here
have made mechanical parts for all of
our lifetime how about taking the
individual structure and the elements
that you're learning so much about and
making tissue from that and organs
eventually is that being actively done
to create manufactured parts if you will
okay so I think both Martha and I spoke
two aspects of that what I tried to
convey in my talk is certainly that is
being done and you saw examples of
we're trying to do that I think there's
also a very forward-looking vision of
the future that yes we will continue to
get an accident so I Drive a motorcycle
trauma might need to have a knee
replaced but you'd love to get away from
having to have replacement parts put in
because you got a disease it'd be much
better you'd be much better off getting
cured the disease very early in the
disease process so that you never have
to go in the hospital and have surgery
anyone who's had surgery knows it's not
a pleasant experience to go in and get
sedated and have things done to you
thank you
we'd like to eat some more lunch so or
eat lunch so thank you thank you